Ich bin erst, na wobei, ich bin erst aufgestanden, stimmt überhaupt nicht. Ich bin eigentlich schon eineinhalb Stunden wach, null.
Kommt mir gar nicht so lange vor.
Muss mal kurz die E-Mails checken, ob es wieder irgendwelche komischen neuen Anfragen gab.
New Partnership von Max FPS, oh ja, das sieht ihr eben, das ist immer äußerst, äußerst einladend, diese E-Mails.
Das ist meistens gern.
Vor allem finde ich geil, dass sie in diesen E-Mails immer schreiben, sie schauen schon jahrelang meinen Channel und voll toller Content und so.
Und dann sind es am Endeffekt irgendwelche, keine Ahnung, China-Chinesen, die kein Deutsch verstehen.
Das ist einfach so der Standard-Intro-Satz, Alter.
Na ja.
Jetzt muss ich erstmal hier ein bisschen aufwachen.
Weiß ich, obwohl ich schon eineinhalb Stunden wach bin, wirklich wach bin ich noch nicht.
Aber ich meine, hey, das ist ein Aufwachen-Stream.
Leute, ihr seid auch schon alle am Start, sehe ich.
Was macht ihr denn so früh schon hier?
Habt ihr noch die Abo-Box von gestern offen?
OMEGALUL
Die Frage ist ja, ist es OMEGALUL oder ist es OMEGALUL?
Der hat übrigens gestern noch die ganzen GitHub-Geschichten fertig gemacht.
Und sogar das, was wir im Stream nicht lösen konnten, mit dem Jeep.
Du willst deine CPU anrufen, weil es dein Kühler bleibt und weniger Strom verbraucht, oder?
Ging das wirklich sowas?
Weil ich meine, im Idle, was es ja zum größten Teil ist, Idle brauchen die ja auch jetzt nicht so in der Welt.
Ich hab das gestern noch hingekriegt, als wir im Stream angefangen haben und dann dank Vodafone nicht fertig machen konnten.
Ich glaub, das war das längste GitHub-Issue aller Zeiten.
Irgendwie 30 Comments oder so, bis es dann funktioniert hat.
Aber ich hab rausbekommen, warum es nicht funktioniert.
Und zwar, die Modellnummer ist bei Fiat ein Int.
Und jetzt kommt's, bei Jeep enthält die Modellnummer auch Zeichen.
Das heißt, da darf es kein Int sein, sondern muss ein String sein.
Deswegen konnte der das nicht easy realisen.
Da muss man erst mal drauf kommen.
Ich glaub nicht, dass das so viel bringt.
Also ich hab mein, bisher nur overvoltet, nicht undervoltet.
Mein i7, mein 8700K, um die dann zu übertakken auf 5,2 Gigahertz, hab ich ja mittlerweile wieder weggemacht.
Und ich hab immer noch keine neue Hardware bestellt.
Das muss ich eigentlich echt jetzt die nächsten Tage machen, sonst wird das diesen Monat nix mehr.
Ich bin immer noch hinterhergerissen, 13900K mit Wasserkühlung.
Oder vielleicht 13700K mit Luftkühlung, aber sag mal so, man kann beides auch mit Luft kühlen.
Aber der 13700 ist ein Ticken leichter mit Luft zu kühlen, nicht wirklich viel.
Im Prinzip ja nur acht, acht, wie heißen diese Dinger, acht Power Safe Kerne mehr.
Sonst ist ja dann nicht allzu viel Unterschied zwischen den CPUs.
Es ist halt insgesamt ein bisschen billiger, weil, also nicht so viel, aber es ist dann auch kleiner.
Kann ich ein kleineres Gehäuse nehmen, anderen Lüfter, kleinere CPUs.
TSFox, danke schön für den Sub.
Hat gar keinen Sound gemacht, oder?
Hab ich das gestern aus Versehen gelöscht, die Subscribe Notifications?
Nee.
Da war Sound? Okay, hab ich gar nicht gehört.
Ja, weil ich hab's hier noch da.
So, Vodafone scheint ihren Shit wieder Together bekommen zu haben.
Ja, 33 Frames, ab und zu kann schon mal passieren.
Wir müssen heute eigentlich noch ne Runde Battlefield spielen.
Ich hab gestern ein paar Runden gespielt gegen die Weekend Noobs.
Leute, 7712 oder so, direkt eine der ersten Runden.
Das ging ab, bam, bababam.
Oh, ich muss meinen Tisch wieder ein bisschen höher machen, stell ich grad fest.
Ich hab den nämlich ein bisschen runter gemacht.
Ich mich beim Aimen nicht so anstrengen muss.
Ja, wenn man ordentlich was treffen will, sollte ja zumindest Arm und Hand und Maus alles auf einer Ebene sein.
Aber normalerweise hab ich den Tisch immer ein bisschen höher, dass der Arm ein bisschen angenehmer aufliegt.
So ist gut. Hab ich's wieder ein bisschen hoch gemacht, besser.
Ja, kann man, aber leider nicht lang.
Die werden jetzt immer mehr Sachen auffallen, die extrem nervig sind und halt quasi kein Support für das Game.
Es ist ja nicht so, als ändern die da was dran.
Also sprich, wenn du jetzt heute feststellst, oh fuck, zum Beispiel ist die meiste Fahrzeugbewaffnung sinnlos.
Das Wichtigste, was du halt gebrauchen kannst, ist zwei spezielle Helitypen und die Mainkanone am Panzer.
Den Rest kannst du eigentlich fast alles vergessen.
Panzer sekundär, also Gunnerplatz im Panzer ist komplett useless.
Diese ganzen anderen Fahrzeuge, die es da gibt, sind zum größten auch useless, damit killst du nix.
Generell ist Fahrzeuge so, als hätte man Fahrzeuge in das Game reingesetzt, ohne dass sie in das Game reinpassen.
Jets kannst du auch vergessen und da muss man halt nicht mit rechnen, dass sie das anpassen.
Seit Anfang an schon so.
Balkon, ich hab keinen Balkon.
Wenn schon, muss es bei mir richtig aufs Dach.
Das ist halt teuer und aktuell lohnt sich das noch nicht so richtig.
Also ich mein, wenn es danach geht, dass ich mir auch kein Elektroauto kaufen dürfte,
rein muss es lohnen, wenn man sich überlegt, wie teuer das war.
Ich weiß schon, ihr habt ja wieder vergessen, wie teuer es war, ich hab es euch erzählt.
Wie viel hat das nochmal gekostet?
23.000 oder so?
Also mit Abzügen und so alles.
Ich hab es, nee 22.000, 23.500, 22.000.
Ich weiß nicht, ich hatte es euch jetzt irgendwie so in dem Dreh.
Was für ein Ausschaber, ein Vier hat 500 E.
Nee, das lohnt sich nicht, wenn ich das bei mir aufs Dach, also das ist nur eine theoretische Sache, wo sich das lohnt.
Also ich hab es mal so grob bei den Daumen gerecht, ich müsste ungefähr 20.000 Euro oder so ausgeben für Solar bei mir auf dem Dach.
Und bis ich das gespart hätte, dann sind wahrscheinlich die Solar-Panels schon im Arsch.
Das ist richtig nice, der Vier hat 500.
Das passt sogar ein bisschen was rein.
Also ich war gestern auf dem Wertstoff, Wertstoff oder wie das denn, da wo man seinen Müll hinbringen kann, was man nicht in die Tonne schmeißt, so Wertstoffhof.
Ich hab in den Koffer, also ich hab hier oben aufgeräumt, hab hier ein paar Bilder auch auf Twitter gepostet von.
Und ich hab insgesamt drei volle Kartons, also so.
Ja gut, Kartons in unterschiedlicher Größe halt, kann ich jetzt schlecht beschreiben, aber große Amazon-Kartons.
Drei große Amazon-Kartons plus zwei Säcke mit alten Zeitungen.
Ich hab meine ganzen alten CTs weggeschmissen, Leute.
Ich hatte ja hier quasi mehrere Stapel CTs, weil ich hab das ja schon abonniert, also ich meine an diese Zeitung.
Ich hab die ja abonniert seit, frag mich nicht, 1998 oder so.
Und ich hab die fast alle noch da gehabt, gehabt.
Und die haben sich halt hier gestapelt, die eine Wand war mehr oder weniger komplett voll damit.
Und die schmeiß ich jetzt mal alle weg.
Weil wozu?
Höchstens zum Sammeln, ja.
Aber ja, wozu soll ich die sammeln? Macht ja keinen Sinn.
Quatsch, nee.
Wie gesagt, ich schmeiß die alle weg, also die Hälfte ist schon ungefähr weg.
Der Rest kommt jetzt auch noch in Müll.
Ich brauch keine CTs von 2005 und sowas, kompletter Blödsinn.
Zumal die online auch ein Archiv haben, wenn man wirklich mal was nachgucken will.
Das stimmt, das hab ich auch gemerkt.
Die Reichweite, also ich würd mal sagen, so 15% Unterschied hast du schon im Winter.
Also natürlich, du brauchst ja auch mehr, ja.
Von Licht bis Heizung, Batterie, Heizung, Innenraumheizung, alles Mögliche.
Und die Batterie ist im Winter auch nicht ganz so ergiebig.
Also ich würd mal sagen, so 15% weniger Reichweite hast du im Winter schon.
Das ist mir auch aufgefallen.
Aber für meine Fahrstrecken hier ist es halt immer noch optimal.
Ich fahr halt immer nur um die Ecke.
Sei es fürs Einkaufen, mal irgendwie Müll wegbringen oder sowas.
Das ist so um die Ecke, das ist überhaupt kein Ding.
Und seitdem ich jetzt endlich auch ein Ladegerät im Hof hab, ist das alles easy.
Jetzt fehlt bloß noch automatisch öffnbares Hoftor.
Da hab ich ja den Motor und die Steuerung so alle schon am Start.
Aber ich muss auf der einen Seite was am Haus vom Nachbar festmachen.
Und irgendwie hab ich den seit gefühlt im halben Jahr nicht mehr gesehen.
Sag mal, wie bist du auf deine neue Arbeit?
Gib uns deine neue Stellaufgabe.
Die haben mich angeschrieben.
Nach meinem Video.
Nach meinem letzten Video, ist eigentlich witzig gewesen.
Ein ehemaliger Kollege hat das Video gesehen, hat gesagt,
sag mal, Max, willst du nicht zu uns, hab ich gesagt, ja erzähl doch mal.
Hat er erzählt, hab ich gesagt, doch, klingt gar nicht so schlecht.
Hab ich den Lebenslauf zusammen gewurstet.
Skilllisten zusammen gewurstet.
Hab das dahingeschickt.
Und die haben mich quasi zwei Tage später oder so eingeladen.
Nein, eine Woche später war es.
Eine Woche später war es.
Das war das Gute daran, ich musste mir kein Anschreiben aus den Fingern saugen.
Ja, das ist in Würzburg.
Na, das ist in Würzburg.
Ja, für meine paar Kilometer Strecken ist das super.
Ja, kann jeder machen, was er will.
Das ist halt die Frage, wie sich das die nächsten Jahre entwickelt.
Kann man nicht mal sehen, wie gut man das abschätzen kann.
Also mal gucken, wenn diese ganzen Elektrogeräte,
Also mal gucken, wenn diese ganze Elektroförderung und sowas ausläuft, nächstes Jahr ist er
schon deutlich weniger als dieses Jahr, was ja auch ein bisschen blöd gemacht ist, dass
die Förderung nicht an den Kaufzeitpunkt, sondern quasi an den Auslieferungszeitpunkt
bzw. den Antragszeitpunkt gebunden ist und den Antrag kann man erst stellen, wenn man
das Auto hat.
Auch ein bisschen blöd, aber gut, mal gucken, wie sich so die Verkaufszahlen entwickeln,
wenn es die ganze Förderung nicht mehr gibt.
Ich glaube, kurzfristig wird das auf jeden Fall erstmal so bleiben, solange es noch Förderung
gibt.
Mal gucken, wie es dann ist.
Auf jeden Fall wird massig überall Ladeinfrastruktur ausgebaut.
Ja, und wie sich das in 10 Jahren entwickelt hat, glaube ich, das kann man eh relativ schlecht
abschätzen.
Es gibt ja Leute, die behaupten, sie können das abschätzen, aber da habe ich so meine
Zweifel.
Ich weiß ja nicht mal, ob in 10 Jahren mein Haus noch steht, so nach dem Motto, also schwierig.
Ja, habe ich, habe ich, habe ich schon gemacht.
350 Euro.
Im Jahr.
Also wenn ich weiß, was das ist, man kann seine, also normalerweise muss ich anders anfangen.
Leute, die mehr Schadstoffe ausstoßen wollen, als erlaubt ist, die müssen sich quasi dazu
Zertifikate kaufen, also die kaufen sich quasi von Leuten, die weniger verbraucht haben,
ihren Anteil ab, dass sie mehr Schadstoffe ausstoßen dürfen und das ging bisher für
private Personen nicht und seit es diese THG-Quote gibt, geht das, also sprich wenn man ein Elektroauto
hat, kann man quasi das, was man an Schadstoffen dadurch einspart, verkaufen, dass andere
wieder mehr Schadstoffe ausstoßen dürfen.
Klingt jetzt erstmal irgendwie kontraproduktiv, aber gibt Geld.
Gibt irgendwie was zwischen 300 und 450 Euro im Jahr, je nachdem wo man hingeht, wie sich
das entwickelt.
Aber ich mein, hey, das ist so, wenn du es nicht machst, bist du blöd, weil das ist verschenkte
Kohle.
Ist ja nicht, als würden die das dann weniger verbrauchen, weil alles was, und das ist ja
der Witz da dran, alles was du nicht verkauft hast, es kann jetzt sein, dass ich es falsch
ausdrücke, aber unterm Strich ist es so, also alles was quasi von diesem Kontingent nicht
verkauft wurde, geht quasi am Ende des Jahres irgendwie auf den Start über und kann trotzdem
verbraucht werden.
Also wenn man jetzt denkt, wenn ich meine Zertifikate nicht verkaufe, dann gibt es weniger
Umweltverschmutzung, nein, nein, nein, nein, nein, so weit kommen werde ich, das geht ja
nicht.
Wenn du deine Zertifikate nicht verkaufst, dann werden die trotzdem verbraucht, bloß
du kein Geld für kriegst.
Also das ist das Beste, was man machen kann.
Gibt es wenigstens ein bisschen Kohle, und da ist die Versicherung im Prinzip schon drinne,
also kann ich davon bezahlen, ja, quasi, kann ich quasi immer der wenige Versicherung bezahlen
und vielleicht auch mal eine oder andere Wartung bezahlen oder sonst was, wobei halt mit 53
Euro kommt man jetzt auch nicht so wahnsinnig weit, aber besser als nichts, ja.
Ja, das ist blödsinnig, das glaube ich nicht, ganz ehrlich, ich gehe auch, also die labern
ja viel bei der Taglange 2035 ein bisschen hin, ich glaube nicht, dass wir bis dahin
so weit sind, dass alle elektrisch fahren wollen, fahren können und anteilmäßig das
so verbreitet ist, das wird bestimmt noch ein bisschen aufgeweicht, die sind ja da immer
recht schnell dabei, auch von wegen generell Autos in den Innenstädten verbieten und so
was, obwohl man noch nicht mal ordentlichen Nahverkehr hat.
So nach dem Motto, ja ihr dürft nicht mehr in die Stadt fahren, aber mit dem Zug fahren
könnt ihr auch nicht, das ist so unüberlegter Kram, zumal was ich halt da, was ich da halt
da ein bisschen blöd finde ist, also ich maße mir nicht an, da die Entwicklung, die Entwicklung
absehen zu können und wer weiß, vielleicht gibt es ja bis dahin irgendwelche super neuen
Technologien, dass sich das wieder lohnt, kann ja alles sein, also ich kann das nicht
abschätzen, was in 13 Jahren ist und ich habe da meine Zweifel, dass das die Leute
irgendwelche Regelungen jetzt schon erlassen, das abschätzen können, also ich kann mir
vorstellen, dass das wieder aufgeweicht wird.
Das ist die eine Richtung klar, das kann sein, dass es so teuer wird, dass es sich
halt überhaupt nicht mehr lohnt und keiner mehr fahren will, kann auch das Umgedrehte
sein, dass irgendwie einer was super geiles erfindet und dann wieder alle draufspringen,
man weiß es nicht, also sieht jetzt zwar aktuell nicht so aus, aber ich mein, wer kann das
schon großartig abschätzen, was da in 12 Jahren alles sich getan hat, guck mal 12
Jahren, da bin ich 50, Keckel, muss man sich mal vorstellen, interessiert mich das alles
nicht mehr.
Ja zum Beispiel, vielleicht erfindet da ja einer was, was sich wirklich lohnt, aktuell
ist es ja eher so, ja kann man machen, lohnt sich aber nicht, aber vielleicht, wie gesagt,
ich kann das nicht abschätzen und ich wage auch zu bezweifeln, dass es super krasse Experten
wirklich gut voraussagen können, klar die haben da mehr Einblick, die können dann
vielleicht eher sagen, ok das ist theoretisch denkbar und das und das geht überhaupt nicht,
aber wie gesagt, keine Ahnung was in 12 Jahren ist, ab und zu, aber sehr sehr selten, wenn
es hochkommt einmal im Monat, das überlebe ich, ne du, danke schön für den Sub, ok der
Sound ist noch da, der Gunray, danke schön für den Sub, meh, das ist nicht gut, ich
danke schön für den Sub, wir gucken jetzt einmal, einmal in die GitHub Trends, das machen
wir immer sonntags morgens, einmal anfangen, einmal, dass ich gucke, was da so neues gibt,
wow, Alter, ich bin blind, Alter, warum ist das so hell, habe ich keinen Dark Reader mehr,
ne warum nicht, ne ist doch noch da, wo ist er denn, ah, wo sind meine Erweiterungen,
wo ist er, da, ah den habe ich ausgemacht, warum das denn, schon viel besser, machst
du beim Advent of Code, ne, schon, schon deutlich besser, viel angenehmer, also was
ist diese Woche getrendet, ok, irgendwelches Machine Learning Kram, der Go Coffee Shop,
Necro Service Demo, ok, Poly, Open Source C++ Library, ja, Facebook, geh mal weg, China-Chinesen-Zeug,
ok was ist das da, habe ich keine Ahnung, achso, irgendeine Sammlung von Links, na toll,
Kall.com, ok, alles klar, soll, ein Kalender, ok, warum auch immer, gerade getrendet, Ecking
Tool, All in One Hacking Tool, ah, das ist genau das Richtige für uns Leute, Easy Hacker
Mode Activated wieder, Snark OS, Rust, ich weiß nicht was es ist, ich weiß nicht was
ZK-Applications sind, hat irgendjemand Ahnung was ZK-Applications sind, bestimmt irgendwelches
Crypto Zeug, ach, Zero Knowledge Applications, ok, jetzt, ich kann nicht mehr was drunter
vorstellen, aber was ist genau, was auch immer, keine Ahnung, Rust Blazingly Fast und überhaupt,
ja, IK Kali Draw, Terefis, Memory Pack, alles klar, gut, nice, GG Eats, ok, ok, ok, jetzt,
Das war nur für heute, ich wollte doch eigentlich die Woche.
Fast Web-Applications für Rust, ich weiß bis heute nicht warum man sein Backend wirklich
in Rust entwickeln sollte, aber gut, Rust hat durchaus seinen Anwendungszweck, aber
als Backend für Web-Anwendungen weiß ich nicht.
Pinch, weiß nicht was es ist, Nintendo Switch Emulator.
Ja gut, nichts großartiges dabei, also was?
Okay, wie wäre es mal mit einem Satz was es ist?
Ich habe keine Ahnung, gut, also wissen wir Bescheid, dass nichts Spannendes trennt.
Super Wiesel, lange schon für den Sub, am Freitag hat sich ein Berufsschullehrer da
aufgeregt, dass ich immer Darkmode benutze, da würden die Augen immer durcheinander,
die Augen kommen nur durcheinander, wenn du Laufen zwischen hell und dunkel switchst,
deswegen habe ich auch Darkreader an im Browser, da ist jetzt nichts, guck hier ist alles darkmoded.
Ja, ich glaube mal das ist was der Berufsschullehrer mit die Augen kommen durcheinander beschreiben
will, dass du geplanet bist, weil der Raum ja hell ist, also aktuell ist es hier alles
andere als hell, außerdem kann man das immer noch so machen, als wenn es hell ist, dass
man normalen Mode, also Lightmode verwendet und ab abends Darkmode oder sowas und richtig
advancede Leute könnten das sogar mit einem Helligkeitssensor im Raum machen, wenn man
will, das wirklich will, ich habe überall Darkmode und fertig, zumal man ja auch selten
das direkt ins Fenster reinguckt, also man sollte ja kein Fenster wirklich hinter dem
Bildschirm haben, das ist auch nicht so das Problem ehrlich gesagt, ja das stimmt auch
wieder, so, was gucken wir uns denn heute an, Servus Leute, der hat mir letztens ein SMS
geschrieben, ich habe darauf geantwortet, habe ich ganz vergessen, jetzt gucken, Chines all
you can eat, ne, ich muss nochmal schreiben, geh mal, geh mal, Sushi futtern wird mal wieder
Zeit und was aufnehmen, oldschool, China all you can eat, fress, stells und aufnehmen,
so also was können wir uns denn anschauen, Gaben almost breaks his monitor, beim Dota
kann ja schon mal passieren, was können wir uns denn angucken, Battlefield 2042 just did
the impossible, das hört sich ja wieder an, man, will er mir wahrscheinlich möchte
er mir mitteilen, das Spiel hat ja sein free weekend und deswegen hat das wieder Spieler
für zwei Tage, hui, impossible Leute, impossible, absolut impossible, ich gucke mir die ersten
zwei Sekunden an, dann weiß ich gleich, ob es Jebait ist oder nicht.
Guckt euch mal an, wie bescheuert schon hier die Animation aussieht, von dem Wind oder
was das sein soll, guck mal, wie beklagt das aussieht, ok, es ist Jebait, es ist Jebait,
es hat lots of players, ja aber das ist nicht, weil sie das impossible gedidet haben, sondern
weil sie es verschenken beziehungsweise drei Tage umsonst spielen lassen, wo genau ist
jetzt das impossible, ok, steam stats, schauen wir mal, ja, ja gut, am dritten und dann,
ja gut, es kostet ja auch gerade nichts, die Grafikqualität ist doch top im Vergleich
zum neuen Pokemon, naja, also erstens läuft das neue Pokemon auch auf der Switch und zweitens
geben die sich überhaupt keine Mühe bei ihren Games und verkacken eigentlich schon seit
irgendwie gefühlt den letzten zehn Jahren, Moment, die neue Map hat Container und Betonplöcke,
hätte ich das gedacht, also ich finde das jetzt wirklich erstaunlich, guck mal, Container,
Betonplöcke, alter, krass sind die kreativ, ne, das ist nicht Level Cap, das ist Jack
Frax zu abwechslung, die werden nach Season 4 eh kaum noch was machen, das ist das, was
ich die ganze Zeit schon sage, weil Season 4, also vier Seasons und dass sie da Specialists
und Maps bringen, haben sie ja im Vorfeld, die haben das ja quasi mit verkauft, ok, jetzt
bringen sie halt noch eine Season 5 mit einer weiteren Map, ja, trotzdem hat das Spiel
immer noch weniger als andere bei Release, gucken wir mal, ok also
eine Battlefield 4 Map portieren nach Battlefield 2042, klingt von der Idee her ja eigentlich
gar nicht schlecht, weil da kannst du einfach alte Maps nehmen und sie quasi in dieses neue,
ja, bisschen, bisschen so Endzeit mäßige Szenario versetzen, Problem ist das Spiel
hat halt nur theoretisch ein Szenario und praktisch siehst du davon halt nix, Angel,
that's it again, wobei ich glaub das gibt's mittlerweile nicht mehr, ne Paracel Storm
machen die nicht, das ist ihnen zu aufwendig, garantiert nicht, ne, Battle Pass ist eher,
wir müssen 100 Level Battle Pass füllen mit 5 interessanten Items und den Rest irgendwie
auffüllen mit unsinnigem Müll und die wichtigen Items so platzieren, dass viele Leute sie
freikaufen mit Microtransaction, zumindest ist das was viele Games mit Battle Passes
machen, so nach dem Motto, ah die richtig guten Sachen sind eigentlich so 80 und 95
und dann, ja das pack ich leider nicht, ja dann kauf ich mal die letzten Battle Passes,
Moment war's das jetzt schon und der Rest ist Gelaber über das aktuelle Gameplay, Alter,
das ist ja mal der krasse G-Bait, 1.40 darüber geredet, dass sie das impossible gedittet
haben, indem sie ein Free Weekend machen, absolut impossible, die Technologie war einfach
bis jetzt noch nicht da ein Free Weekend zu machen, ich glaube es gab sogar noch mal ein
Free Weekend, relativ am Anfang, G-Baited, Jack-Frags, G-Baited, alles klar, das hat
es ja richtig gelohnt zu gucken, was ist das, IBMs New Lightspeed Processor shocks die
Entire Industry, solche Titel sind meistens ziemlich harter G-Bait, Titel die auch beliebt
sind, sind sowas wie This Changes Everything und sowas, wo dir dann denkst du, ja wie viele
Sachen gab's wirklich schon die Everything gechanget haben, jeder Titel ist G-Bait,
Moment, wollt ihr etwa sagen, dass dieser Titel hier auch G-Bait ist, kann überhaupt
nicht sein, ich mein, hallo, bald Arbeitslos, aber das beste was man machen kann ist einfach
in seine Thumbnails und Titel ein Fragezeichen machen, weil wenn man ein Fragezeichen rein
macht, kann man dort das eine schreiben und im Video das andere sagen und wenn sich einer
beschwert sagst du, ja hast du denn das Fragezeichen nicht gesehen, ganz einfach, einfach immer
Fragezeichen rein machen, ok wir gucken uns mal an, wie es die Entire Industry schockt,
ja gut, naja gut, man muss mal sagen, es gibt also die Zeiten von, innerhalb von einem
halben Jahr oder einem Jahr ist das Ding dreimal so schnell, wie es sag mal so 2000 darum war,
also zwischen sag mal 1995 und 2005 oder so vielleicht noch, so krass ist es nicht mehr
und wird es wahrscheinlich auch nicht werden und es gab, muss ich jetzt sagen, kann ich
an der Stelle mal erzählen, nice Fun Fact, es gab mal eine Roadmap von Intel aus dem
Jahr, weiß nicht genau 1996 oder so und mal gucken ob wir die finden, 1997 vielleicht
ja und ach interessant ja und dort hatten sie CPUs drinne mit bis zu 10 Gigahertz, nee
das ist falsch, ja, alter wie soll man das, wie soll man das bitte schön, nee das meine
ich nicht, das meine ich nicht, die hatten, also mal gucken ob wir die Roadmap finden,
die hatten eine Roadmap, da standen Technologien drinne und zwar grün, orange und rot und grüne
Technologien war, wo man schon, also grüne Punkte war, wo man schon wusste wie man das
Problem löst, orangene Sachen waren, wir haben uns, wir haben eine Lösungsidee, wissen
aber nicht genau wie wir es machen und rot ist, wir haben keinen Plan wie wir es umsetzen
und umso weiter in die Zukunft diese Roadmap ging, umso mehr rot wurde da halt, wir suchen
einfach nach old Intel Roadmap, keine Ahnung, keine Ahnung wo das Ding ist, zumindest hatten
die da CPUs drinne bis zu 10 Gigahertz und das war halt die Roadmap bevor irgendjemand
auf die glorreiche Idee gekommen ist, quasi zwei CPUs in eine zu bauen, also mehrere CPU-Kerne
und diese Roadmap hatte halt überhaupt keinen Bestand, aber man hat sich halt gedacht ok
das und das könnte man in Zukunft machen, hat halt nicht funktioniert, wo sind wir denn
stehen geblieben überhaupt, TF, also die Zeiten sind vorbei, dass sich das super sprunghaft
entwickelt so wie sich das Intel vorgestellt hat, die Roadmap ging damals bis keine Ahnung
2010 oder so und da waren halt CPUs drinne 10 Gigahertz plus, was halt nie passiert ist
und selbst, da sieht man es mal wieder wie es mit Sachen ist vorherzusagen in zwölf
Jahren, selbst Intel kann ihre eigenen Sachen absolut nicht gescheit vorhersagen für die
nächsten 10 Jahre, also sprich warum soll das irgendjemand der sich jetzt Gesetze ausdenkt
wirklich können, also das ist vorbei, die Zeit, dass es irgendwie ein Jahr braucht und
die Sachen sind doppelt bis dreimal so schnell, gerade zu Zeiten von den ersten Voodoo Grafikkarten
war das so, also im GPU Sektor ging das so extrem schnell, also CPU auch, Festplattenplatz
auch, aber GPU technisch ging das mega schnell, überlegt mal, wir haben uns von irgendwie
nicht 3D über irgendwie die ersten ATI Rage 3D und was es nicht auch so gab, über Voodoo
Rage 2 bis zur ersten Nvidia TNT, Riva TNT hieß das Ding glaube ich noch, da hochgearbeitet,
das waren immer Sprünge Leute, das war einfach immer innerhalb von einem Jahr war das gefühlt
oder innerhalb von 2 Jahren war das 3-4 mal so schnell, das ging übelst ab, die Zeiten
sind natürlich vorbei, aber trotzdem wird es in Zukunft auch noch schneller werden,
ich meine vergleich mal ein 8700K mit einem 13900K, natürlich wenn du Benchmarks nimmst,
dann ist es hauptsächlich erstmal der Sache zu verdanken, dass das Ding mehr Kerne hat,
aber auch wenn du CPU Single Thread oder Single Core Performance nimmst, ist das glaube ich
56% besser oder so mittlerweile, ja das ist, da sind ein paar Jahre dazwischen und es ist
ja vielleicht, sag mal wenn wir großzügig sind, wobei die net 56% sogar noch mehr mittlerweile,
ja gut egal, da sind jetzt 5 Jahre dazwischen und wir sind vielleicht nur doppelt so schnell
geworden in 5 Jahren, Single Core, ok ja, aber das wird auch noch weiter so gehen, also
wir werden da trotzdem auch noch Fortschritte erleben, natürlich klar wenn jetzt einer
wirklich eine bahnbrechende neue Technologie erfinden sollte, was sich aber keiner mal
so aus dem Ärmel schüttelt, mal gucken ob IBM das hier hinkriegt, ich hab's ja meine
zweifel, dann kann das wieder so werden wie Anfang der 2000er, aber da rechne ich erstmal
nicht damit.
Nee, nee, nee, nee, das ist sowas was in der Theorie vielleicht gut funktioniert aber
aktuell ist das auf jeden Fall noch nicht so, was ist das, das ist ja die bescheuertste
Erklärung ever alter, ein Transistor hat, naja ok, ok, ok das ist ein Video für irgendwelche
Omas die das gucken oder so, ein Transistor ist in der Regel also eigentlich eine relativ
simple Geschichte, das Problem ist das wir mittlerweile Millionen und Milliarden davon
haben, mit Abständen die ja keiner mehr so wirklich greifen kann.
Aha.
Ups...
Aber was genau hat das jetzt eigentlich mit neuem IBM Lightspeed Prozessor zu tun?
Gunray, ja stimmt, das ist wirklich eine übelst bescheuerte Erklärung.
Moment, Moment, das ist... nein, nein, nein, nein, nein, nein, der Transistor ist nicht
dafür gedacht, das irgendwie zu storen oder so. Also die Logik ergibt sich aus dem Verbinden.
Das ist tatsächlich gar nicht so verkehrt, wenn man das an der Stelle mit dem Gehirn
vergleicht. Was weiß ich, wie viele Neuronen im Gehirn sind erstmal zweitrangig. Die Verbindung
ist ja das eigentlich Wichtige. Und wichtig in der CPU ist auch, was du mit den Transistoren machst.
Du hast die Roadmap, ja, pauste mal, pauste mal. Also wie du die miteinander verschaltest,
dass du dann logische Operationen damit ausführen kannst. Und ein Transistor
stort nicht, ein Transistor macht das, was du am Input anlegst.
Inoffizielle Roadmap von Intel. Ja, das kann's, nee, das ist nicht die Roadmap.
Ich dachte, das war ein Bild. Das war ein Bild mit grün, orange und rot.
Nee, nee. Das ist von 2003. Aber guck mal, 9,2 Gigahertz und sowas. Jaja, es geht in die Richtung.
Okay, Alter, kommst du jetzt mal zum neuen Lightspeed Prozessor, bitteschön?
Ja, das ist nämlich das, was ich meine. Du musst den Gramm zusammen benutzen. Und ja,
übrigens der Transistor an sich speichert das nicht. Der Transistor macht das,
was du immer am Input anlegst. What the fuck? Ja, ist ja gut, jetzt komm mal zum Punkt, man.
Okay, das Video ist die Hälfte rum. Wir haben noch nicht mit dem Titel zu tun gehabt.
Nein, und das weiß man auch schon seit einer ganzen Weile.
Das stimmt. Moment, Moment, Moment. Es geht vor allem auch um die Abstände dazwischen.
Das ist auch eine entscheidende Sache.
Okay, also im Prinzip alles nur theoretisches Blabla, was wir uns da jetzt erzählen. So von
wegen IBMs, New Lightspeed, Schocks. Die schockt die andere Industrie erst,
wenn es die Dinge gibt und vor allem, wenn sie es dann auch halten.
Hä? Was, was wollen die, sorry, was wollen die mir
überhaupt jetzt sagen damit? Also im Prinzip ist es nicht, dass IBMs neuer Lightspeed Prozessor die
Industrie schockt. Sie erzählen über irgendwelche theoretische Möglichkeiten, wie man das bauen
könnte, was nicht mehr auf klassischer Halbleiter-Technik basiert. Nice. Next. Alter, was ein Rotz, man.
Richtig nice Gebate. You should be using Portman. Ich kann es auch sein lassen. Was haben wir denn
hier? Paradox. Weniger Arbeitszeit gleich mehr Produktivität. Ja, das sage ich seit Jahren
schon. Vor allem, vor allem nicht nur, nicht nur, dass man die Zeit besser ausnutzt. Nein,
man ist auch selbst entspannter. Man ist wacher. Es geht einem allgemein besser. Man ist weniger
reizbar. Man hat bessere Ideen, ist kreativ. Also alles, alles ist besser, wenn man weniger
arbeitet. Auch für den Arbeitgeber. Mal gucken, ob das, okay, das weiß ich jetzt nicht, ob das
belegt ist, aber aus meiner Sicht ist es so. Ich meine, weil die müssen nicht auch weniger
bezahlen, wenn man weniger arbeitet. Ist ja logisch. So, gucken wir mal. Es gibt übrigens
noch einen Grund, noch einen weiteren Grund für weniger Arbeit. Wir sollten mal ein bisschen
mehr Technologie für uns arbeiten lassen, anstatt selbst den ganzen Tag zu schuften.
Was jetzt? YouTube, please. Los geht's. In den letzten 20 Jahren ist die Anzahl an Toten,
die man mit Überlastung auf der Arbeit zusammenbringen konnte, laut WHO um fast 30% gestiegen.
Zumal es ja auch viele Jobs gibt, wo es keine Nachfolger mehr gibt. Zum Beispiel Berger
Beiter oder so was. Und auch vieles, was sich in Fabriken und so heute noch von Hand gemacht
wird, da ist ja die letzten Jahre über schon viel verschwunden. Also ich könnte mir vorstellen,
einige Jobs sterben komplett aus, aktuell gerade. Ich habe mal angeschaut, welche positiven
und negativen Auswirkungen das hat und was die Forschung dazu sagt. Und damit willkommen
bei Breaking Lab, Jakob hier. Los geht's. Auf geht's. Immer mehr Unternehmen und Länder
exponentieren aktuell mit der Viertagewoche. Mit dabei sind Länder wie Island und auch
Großbritannien, große Techfirmen wie Microsoft, aber zum Beispiel auch ein Handwerksunternehmen
am Boden sehen. Belgien hat tatsächlich im Februar sogar das Recht auf eine Viertagewoche
gesetzlich beschlossen. Sweet. Viertage bedeutet hier jetzt aber nicht, dass man weniger arbeiten
kann. Na, Handwerker wirst du wahrscheinlich auf absehbare Zeit immer noch brauchen. Die
Arbeitnehmer dürfen in Belgien ihre 40-Stunden-Woche einfach nur auf 4 Tage verteilen. Das bedeutet
dann also... Das habe ich übrigens von vielen Leuten auch schon gehört, sie würden das
hier auch gerne machen. Also quasi dann 10 Stunden arbeiten an 4 Tagen anstatt 8. Prinzip
ist es ja dann quasi noch 2 Stunden länger absitzen, weil niemand schafft 10 Stunden
am Tag. Das sage ich ja auch schon lange. Niemand arbeitet wirklich 8 Stunden am Tag
durch. Gerade in Berufen, wo man halt auch ein bisschen denken muss. Also bei körperlichen
Berufen ist es relativ obvious, dass du nicht 8 Stunden am Tag Schwerstarbeit verrichten
kannst. Aber auch bei 5-Hat-Jobs, wo man nachdenken muss, du kannst nicht 8 Stunden
am Tag kreativ sein und irgendwie neue Sachen ausdenken. Ich glaube die Produktivität erstreckt
sich bei den meisten Leuten vielleicht so auf 1,5-2 Stunden am Tag, wo wirklich sinnvoll
was rumkommt. Der Rest ist halt Sachen, die gemacht werden müssen oder Zeit absitzen.
Ist halt auch nicht sinnvoll. Einige Unternehmen haben aber auch Testläufe mit reduzierter
Stundenanzeige gestartet. Die Befürworter der 4-Tage-Woche sagen, dass weniger Arbeit
glücklicher, gesünder und sogar produktiver macht. Und die Gegner, die fürchten sinkende
Produktivität, hohe Kosten oder schätzen das Ganze halt einfach als nicht durchführbar
ein. Unser Arbeitsmodell der 5-Tage-Woche ist tatsächlich schon über 100 Jahre alt
und hat sich seitdem kaum verändert. Während der industriellen Revolution hat man sogar
eher so 15 Stunden am Tag und zwar 6 bis sogar 7 Tage die Woche gearbeitet. 1918 wurde dann
in Deutschland der 8-Stunden-Tag offiziell eingeführt, was zwischendurch auch wieder
etwas aufgeweicht wurde. Aber generell gab es am Konzept eigentlich nur ganz kleine
Änderungen. Schauen wir uns also mal die neuesten Entwicklungen an. Ein Vorreiter beim
Thema 4-Tage-Woche ist Island. Da wurde schon im Jahr 2015 eines der größten Pilotprojekte
gestartet. Innerhalb von 4 Jahren wurden dort 2 Studien durchgeführt und insgesamt haben
über 100 Unternehmen mit etwa 2500 Mitarbeitenden teilgenommen. Das klingt jetzt vielleicht
erstmal nicht nach einer riesigen Menge, aber weil in Island gar nicht so viele Menschen
überleben, war das schon ein Prozent der... Island ist wirklich nicht so viel.... gesamten
berufstätigen Bevölkerung. Während der Studienzeit wurde die wöchentliche Arbeitszeit von einer
40-Stunden-Woche auf eine 35- oder 36-Stunden-Woche umgestellt. Und die Ergebnisse der Studie
waren so überwältigend positiv, dass Islands-Gewerkschaften eine langfristige Reduzierung der Arbeitsstunden
erreicht haben und nun rund 86% der Erwerbstätigen zu einer kürzeren Woche übergegangen sind
oder immerhin... Tschüss Max, Dankeschön für den Sub. Am 19.11. ab 18 Uhr gibt es wieder
einen Livestream hier auf YouTube. Jährlich erkranken allein in Deutschland über 500.000
Menschen an Krebs. Ich hab mir die Frage gestellt, wieso... Das ging jetzt aber, das ging jetzt
aber schnell. Ach, das ist Werbung.... mit super spannenden Wissenschaftlerinnen und
Wissenschaftlern, wie z.B. am 19.11. ab 18 Uhr. Es wird ja häufig befürchtet, dass es durch
die Arbeitszeitverkürzung zu vielen Überstunden kommt oder einfach der Outcome der... Ne,
das glaube ich nicht, dass es zu vielen Überstunden kommt, weil viele Leute einfach die Zeit absitzen.
Gerade mit Zeiterfassung so nach dem Motto, du musst am Tag anwesend sein. Also es wird
ja für die Anwesenheit bezahlt, nicht für die Arbeit in vielen Fällen. Und das glaube
ich nicht, die gehen einfach früher heim und es ändert sich nichts. Der Unternehmen
reduziert wird, um so ein bisschen in diesem BWL-Sprech zu sein. Und die Ergebnisse aus
Island, die zeigen tatsächlich genau das Gegenteil. Die Produktivität da hat sich während der
Zeit entweder gar nicht verändert oder ist sogar gestiegen. Als Schlüssel zu diesem Erfolg
gilt eine neue Arbeitsorganisation. Also Meetings, die werden jetzt verkürzt oder zu E-Mails
umgewandelt und gewohnte... Wait a minute, mit weniger sinnlosem Gelaber und Gemiete
am Tag schafft man mehr. Echt jetzt? Also das hätte ich jetzt nicht gedacht. Die wurden
neu aufgebaut und effizienter gemacht. Und auch ganz wichtig, die Arbeitsmotivation ist
durch mehr Freizeit wohl gestiegen. Solche Ergebnisse... Und die Leute sind motivierter,
wenn sie nicht so viel auf der Arbeit krammeln müssen. Nein, wirklich. Aber ich finde es
gut, dass es so offiziell jetzt auch irgendwie selbst gehalten wird, irgendwelche Untersuchungen.
Ich meine, eigenes Gefühl ist ja immer das eine. Das müssen ja nicht viele Leute teilen,
aber das hätte mich auch sehr gewundert, wenn es andersrum wäre. Japana ausgerechnet.
Denn Japan ist zu seinen extremen hohen Wochenarbeit. Ausgerechnet ein Japaner, man. Bei Microsoft
bekam alle 2300 Beschäftigten für 5 Wochen bei gleichem Monatsgehalt den Freitag frei.
Mit neuer Organisation, kürzeren Meetings und mehr Fernkommunikation konnte eine Produktivitätssteigerung
von unglaublichen 40% erreicht werden. Pass mal auf, pass mal auf. Japanlogik ist jetzt,
wir haben offiziell nur noch vier Tage, an denen wir arbeiten. Das heißt, wir müssen
an den vier Tagen das schaffen, was wir an fünf Tagen schaffen. Und weil der Chef am
Freitag auch ins Büro geht, erscheinen wir Freitag selbstverständlich auch im Büro,
stechen aber nicht ein, aber arbeiten trotzdem. Das ist Japanlogik wahrscheinlich. Wahrscheinlich
haben die fünf Tage gearbeitet, aber in vier Tagen schon das geschafft, was sie in fünf
Tagen schafften, haben quasi am fünften Tag für den sechsten Tag geschafft. Das wird
mich da echt nicht wundern, Alter.
Mit flexlieberen Arbeitszeiten die Kreativität und Produktivität der Leute dort zu fördern
und ich würde sagen, 40% mehr Produktivität, das klingt gar nicht so verkehrt. Auch nicht
für BWL-Justus. Und dieses Wachstum an Produktivität, das kann natürlich jetzt auf der einen Seite
an mehr Zufriedenheit und Motivation liegen, aber dass die Produktivität nicht einbricht,
hat wahrscheinlich noch einen ganz anderen Grund. Die Leute sind wacher, und fitter.
Ach nee. Jetzt bin ich gespannt. Ok, es ist tatsächlich mehr als ich gesagt habe. Ich
habe gesagt eineinhalb bis zwei Stunden, wo wirklich was passiert am Tag. Ok, es sind
fast drei Stunden. Das erscheint mir fast schon bei kreativen Tätigkeiten. Ok, drei
Stunden über den Tag verteilt, unterbrochen von Mittagessen, Meetings und sonst was. Ja,
vielleicht. Ich meine halt so mal eineinhalb Stunden am Stück schaffen. Kommt halt bei
mir relativ selten vor, weil entweder ruft einer im Teams an oder es gibt irgendein Meeting
oder haste nicht gesehen sonst was.
In den restlichen fünf Stunden werden Nachrichten gelesen, mit Kollegen gesocialized, gegessen
oder Kaffee getrunken, Raucherpausen. Man surft ein bisschen online. Und das hat eine
Umfrage mit knapp 2000 britischen Büroangestellten ergeben. Und die vollen acht Stunden, die
war ja meist nur im Büro verbracht, weil es eben so vorgeschrieben ist. Und zu diesen
Ergebnissen kamen auch noch ein paar andere Studien. Neben der Produktivität ist tatsächlich
auch die Gesundheit ein wichtiges Thema. Und so gut wie alle Teilnehmerinnen und Teilnehmer
aus der Studie in Island haben von einem deutlich gesteigerten Wohlbefinden berichtet.
Ja, das kann ich euch auch nur berichten, Leute. Das ist der Grund, warum ich seit Jahren,
man könnte fast schon sagen Jahrzehnten, aber ist es glaube ich nicht. Ich mache das glaube
ich erst seit 2012 oder so, nur noch vier Tage Woche arbeite. Genau, das ist der Grund,
dir geht es einfach besser. Und drei Tage Wochenende am Stück ist halt einfach prog.
Selbstzeit und nachhaltig anhält. Stresssymptome und Schlafstörungen, die wurden verbessert
und es blieb mehr Energie übrig für Sport, Hobbys oder auch das Familienleben. Und es
gibt natürlich auch viele Studien, die einen stärkeren Zusammenhang zwischen langen Arbeitszeiten
2012 ist jetzt ein Jahrzehnt, ja, folgend für die Gesundheit herausgefunden haben.
Beispielsweise erhöht sich mit mehr Arbeitszeit auch das Risiko für Bluthochdruck, Herzkreislauferkrankungen,
Erschöpfungserscheinungen und einen schlechteren allgemeinen Zustand. Der Einfluss auf die
körperliche Gesundheit kann natürlich jetzt auch ein sekundärer Effekt sein, also zum
Beispiel, dass auch eine Person aus Zeitgründen seltener Sport macht und sich ungesünder
ernährt. Das heißt, es war einfach so eine Gleiterscheinung davon. So ähnlich sieht
es auch bei der psychischen Gesundheit aus. Mit mehr Arbeitszeit steigt auch das Risiko
an einer Depression zu erkranken. Das wundert mich nicht, dass es den Leuten besser geht,
wenn sie wenig arbeiten. Also wenn sie weniger arbeiten müssen. Psychische Erkrankungen
sind tatsächlich mit 33,5 Prozent mit Abstand der häufigste Grund für eine Berufsunfähigkeit.
Also das sollte man definitiv nicht unterschätzen, ganz wichtig zu betonen. Es gab jetzt aber
noch andere Aspekte, die ich an dieser isländischen Studie ziemlich spannend fand. Also ein Tag
mehr Freizeit in der Woche führt dort zum Beispiel dazu, dass Männer öfter im Haushalt
mitgeholfen haben, was wahrscheinlich viele Frauen dazu hatten, was sie sehr gefreut
haben. Und bevor wir jetzt von hier aus die großen...
Ich meine, die haben dann weniger Belastung, sind nicht so fertig. Ich meine ansonsten,
wer hat Bock noch großartig was zu machen, wenn er morgens um 6 Uhr aufsteht, abends
um 18 Uhr heimkommt, den ganzen Tag unterwegs war, geschafft hat und fertig ist und sich
eigentlich nur noch ausruhen will. Und dann kommt noch so, ja wir müssen über irgendwas
diskutieren und ja wir müssen uns jetzt hier noch drum kümmern und sonst wie. Natürlich
da haben die Leute kein Bock. Und wenn ein Tag weniger ist, ist es einfach deutlich
entspannter. Was machst du denn so an deinem 3-Tage-Wochenende? Äh zum Beispiel Streams
auf Twitch oder YouTube-Videos. Aber um die negativen Aspekte kommen erstmal noch eine
positive Sache. Und zwar eine britische Studie geht davon aus, dass eine Umstellung auf
eine 4-Tage-Woche bis 2025 den CO2-Fußabdruck Großbritanniens um 127 Millionen Tonnen pro
Jahr verringern könnte. Das kann ich mir gut vorstellen. Das kann ich mir gut vorstellen.
Von etwa 21%. Das sind etwa so viel wie der CO2-Ausstoß aller britischen Privatwagen
auf der Straße. Also immens viel. Im Gegensatz zu anderen Studien geht das britische Modell
von einem gleichbleibenden Wirtschaftswachstum aus. Sonst kann sich die Verringerung des
CO2-Ausstoß ja auch durch sinkendes Einkommen oder sinkende Produktion und weniger Konsum
erklären lassen. Ein wichtiger Faktor für die Klimabilanz ist der reduzierte Stromverbrauch
in Büros und Produktionen. Und wenn das Wochenende ein Tag länger andauert, dann fährt man ja
auch nicht so oft ins Büro. Das stimmt. Natürlich reicht jetzt auch der private Energieverbrauch,
weil dieser Mehrverbrauch, der wird in der Studie mit den Ersparnissen gegengerechnet.
Das Ergebnis ist, dass in Großbritannien auf diese Weise etwa 117.000 Tonnen CO2 wöchentlich
eingespart werden können. Übrigens hat tatsächlich auch Microsoft durch diese 4 Tage Woche positive
Auswirkungen für die Umwelt festgestellt. Im Vergleich zum Vorjahr ging der Stromverbrauch
um 23%...
Ja. Auf geht's Leute. Für die Umwelt. Wir arbeiten alle weniger. Easy. Bin ich sofort
dabei.
...50% weniger Papierseiten gedruckt. Aber das könnte ja tatsächlich auch so ein Nebeneffekt
sein.
Und wenn dann einer kommt, Max, wie? Du bist einfach nur faul, du willst nicht mehr arbeiten,
sage ich, nee. Macht das alles der Umwelt zuliebe. Was natürlich ein guter Nebeneffekt ist,
ja.
...Digitalisierungsprozesse. Es gibt außerdem auch eine Reihe an Studien, die einen Zusammenhang
zwischen langen Arbeitszeiten und umweltschädlichen Konsummustern feststellen. Eine US-Studie
hat den CO2-Fuseabdruck von Gütern mit Daten zum Konsumverhalten kombiniert. Das Ergebnis
ist, dass Haushalte mit längeren Arbeitszeiten durch ihren Konsum viel mehr CO2 verursachen.
Also Menschen mit mehr Zeit, die gehen dann öfter mal selber einkaufen oder kochen.
Aha.
Oder auf Lieferdienste. Und tatsächlich ist es auch so, dass sie dann seltener das Auto
verwenden und weniger einkaufen.
Das stimmt wohl. Ich laufe total viel rum in letzter Zeit. Ich war viel zu Fuß, ja.
Zoom scheint da echt mit zusammen zu hängen. Wahrscheinlich weil viele Leute sich glücklich
kümmern.
Vor allem, ja, nee, vor allem, wenn du Zeit hast, ja.
Das ist meine persönliche Vermutung. Könnt ihr gerne mal sagen, warum ihr glaubt, warum
das so ist? Und an dieser Stelle kommen wir jetzt mal vom Positiven zum großen Aber.
Weil du Zeit hast.
Ein paar Aspekte muss man auf jeden Fall auch kritisch betrachten. Da bleibt zum einen
mal dieser Klimaaspekt. Denn mehr Zeit fördert vielleicht jetzt auch mehr so Kurztrips irgendwo
hin.
Und ein weiterer Punkt ist die Frage, wie unterschiedliche Branchen die Viertagewoche
umsetzen können. Wenn der Freitag wirklich für alle Mitarbeitenden frei ist und so die
Büros geschlossen bleiben, haben wir positive Effekte. Einige Einrichtungen unter Unternehmen
müssen aber jeden oder fast jeden Tag geöffnet sein. Polizei, Feuerwehr, Krankenhaus.
Ja, da gibt es ein ganz einfaches Mittel. Mehr Personal. Dann können nämlich die Leute
vier Tage arbeiten. Es sind trotzdem noch andere Leute da. Es müssen ja nicht automatisch
alle am Freitag frei haben. Manche können ja auch am Montag frei haben.
Häuser, Fliegereinrichtungen und sowas. Und da wäre dann eine Lösung, dass die Schichten
so verlängert werden, dass alle Tage abgedeckt werden. Aber eigentlich ist das Ziel der Viertagewoche
ja mehr Ausgeglichenheit und Entspannung zu haben und jetzt nicht längere Schichten.
Die andere Möglichkeit ist natürlich dann wieder mehr Personal einzustellen, was wieder
für höhere Kosten sorgt, was dann wieder einen negativen Effekt auf das Wirtschaftliche
hält. Es kann aber auch Nachteile für den Arbeitnehmer geben. Erstmal ist der Übergang
von der 5 auf die Viertagewoche wahrscheinlich schwierig und braucht recht viel Organisation.
Weil, wisst ihr was das Schwierigste ist? Das Boomer-Hirn von sowas zu überzeugen bei
den Leuten, die sowas entscheiden.
Wenn es einfach von jetzt auf gleich heißt, man muss das gleiche Arbeitspensum in 4 statt
5 Tagen bewältigen, kann es jetzt auch zu so einer Arbeitsverdichtung und folgenden
Stresserscheinungen kommen. Genau das möchte man ja eigentlich verhindern. Es gibt aber
auch Bedenken zum Arbeitsklima und zum sozialen Austausch. Also wenn Meetings zu E-Mails verwandelt
werden und die Pausen kürzer ausfallen, dann kann dadurch natürlich auch die soziale
Interaktion sein.
Das ist, das ist blödsinn, ganz ehrlich. Die meisten Meetings werden einfach nur sinnlos
gestreckt.
Insgesamt finde ich das Thema ziemlich komplex.
Und wisst ihr, ich muss jetzt mal einen Punkt ansprechen. Wisst ihr was ich sehr merkwürdig
finde?
Das ist auch was, was wir bei mir auf der Arbeit oftmals so als Pro oder Contra Homeoffice
anführen.
Und zwar, letztens hat doch wirklich auf einer Veranstaltung einer erzählt, die Firma,
also der Firma wäre daran gelegen, dass die Leute ins Büro kommen, um sie vor sich selbst
zu schützen, so nach dem Motto.
Weil die Leute ja sonst daheim vereinsamen und da sieht die Firma quasi einen Bedarf,
dass sie darauf aufpassen, dass die Leute nicht zu Hause vereinsamen.
Deswegen müssen sie jetzt gefälligst ins Büro kommen.
Und auf die Frage hin, auf die Frage hin, dass ja viele Leute gekündigt haben, würden
oder erst gar nicht anfangen bei der Firma, weil es keine ordentlichen Homeoffice-Regelungen
gibt, war die Antwort, nee, nee, das ist eher das Gegenteil.
Man hat in einem Bewerbungsgespräch schon total oft gehört, dass die Leute gesagt haben,
oh, ihr habt aber eine so schöne Office-Kultur hier, da komme ich aber gerne.
Kein Spaß, kein Spaß, haben sie wirklich erzählt.
Ich denke mir, wer will, kann das ja machen, absoluter Wahnsinn.
Das haben die wahrscheinlich im Vorstellungsgespräch gesagt, ich meine im Vorstellungsgespräch
erzählen die Leute dann alles, dass sie einen guten Eindruck machen.
Aber ansonsten ist das halt, naja, blödsinn, wo sind wir denn stehen geblieben?
Also wenn Meetings zu E-Mails verwandelt werden.
Ach ja, genau, jetzt weiß ich, was ich sagen wollte.
Und mit dieser ganzen Vereinsamung muss ich halt sagen, warum tun eigentlich alle so bei
diesen Diskussionen, als ist die Arbeit der einzige Ort von sozialer Interaktion.
Ich meine, wenn ich mit anderen Leuten interagieren möchte, dann kann ich das x-beliebig woanders
machen, auch außerhalb von der Arbeit.
Also wenn ich zum Beispiel frei habe am Freitag, kann ich mit meiner Familie irgendwo hinfahren,
da habe ich auch soziale Interaktion.
Oder ein bisschen in irgendeinen Park gehen oder Leute, die super gerne mit anderen Leuten
zusammensitzen, sollen halt keine Ahnung, einen Tanzkurs machen oder in irgendeinen
Verein gehen oder sowas.
Ich meine, wenn du soziale Interaktion haben willst, du musst die ja nicht zwangsläufig
auf der Arbeit machen.
Und wer nicht will, so wie ich, lässt es bleiben.
Und ganz im Ernst, ich habe, also meine Erfahrung ist, ich kann im Homeoffice oder generell
mit Leuten, die Online-Spiele-Erfahrung haben im Homeoffice und im Homeoffice sitzen, deutlich
besser kommunizieren als vor Ort.
Vor Ort sind die Leute quasi den ganzen Tag am Telefonieren, irgendwo unterwegs, sitzen
in irgendwelchen Meetings und bei mir, wenn ich im Homeoffice sitze, gucke ich, aha, der
Typ ist grün im Teams, ich schreibe ihn an, fünf Minuten später, spätestens melde, dass
ich, wir labern mal kurz, viertel Stunde, ungut ist.
Ich habe glaube ich im Homeoffice mehr von den Leuten, von meinen Kollegen mitgekriegt,
bei denen gerade auch privat und drumherum so abgeht, als ich es jemals im Büro mitgekriegt
habe.
Man hat halt einfach mal kurze Viertelstunde geschwätzt und hat dann vielleicht noch,
keine Ahnung, zehn Minuten hinten dran gehängt, nochmal über andere Sachen geschwätzt.
Ich habe mehr mitgekriegt in der Homeoffice-Teil als vor Ort und der Informationsfluss ist
besser und schneller im Homeoffice gewesen, jetzt nicht bei so Sachen wie, was auf irgendwelchen
Management-Ebenen entschieden wurde und manche Sachen ist natürlich flur-funk-technisch
schon nicht verkehrt, aber im Team die Kommunikation, muss ich sagen, die war im Homeoffice bei
uns zumindest besser als vor Ort, gerade weil die Leute auch einfach mal Sachen, anstatt
das irgendwie am Kaffeeautomat oder, ach hier, wenn du gerade mal da bist, erzählt haben,
haben die es einfach in den Teams-Channel geschrieben, da hat das dann nicht nur derjenige
mitgekriegt, der zufälligerweise mal in der Küche zum richtigen Zeitpunkt gestanden
hat, nein, sondern es haben alle mitgekriegt, die in diesen Teams-Channel geguckt haben.
Naja, das sind aber auch die, die sagen, wir sind, ja, das kenne ich auch, das machen
ja manche Unternehmen gerne, was aber halt kompletter Blödsinn ist, weil, okay, was
ich schreibe, weil sie denken, Arbeit ist der einzige Ort, wo ich Leute treffe, nee,
zum Geld verdienen, korrekt, korrekt, das heißt nicht, dass man da nicht gerne hingehen
kann, ja, aber der, sagen wir mal, der Hauptmotivator ist jetzt nicht, ich gehe da gerne hin, weil
ich das so geil finde, sondern erstmal, ich gehe da hin, weil ich Geld verdiene, wenn
das dann natürlich auch jetzt nicht vielleicht ganz scheiße ist, ist das natürlich schon
mal gut, aber ansonsten ist ja der Hauptmotivator dahinter erstmal Geld, und ansonsten, diese
Aussagen dienen einzig und allein dazu, dass die Leute quasi mehr arbeiten für das gleiche
oder weniger Geld, so nach dem Motto, ja, wir sind doch so dicke und wir helfen uns
alle gegenseitig und gerade sind die Zeiten so schlecht, deswegen mehr Geld, mehr Geld
ist schlecht, aber wir haben uns doch alle so lieb und wir mögen uns doch alle so und
wir machen dann auch ein cooles Sommerfest und sowas, ich meine, ist ja schön und gut
für alle Leute, die gerne auf Sommerfeste gehen, aber ich habe lieber 500 Euro mehr
im Monat als ein cooles Sommerfest oder solche Sachen, nee, ist halt viel Geschwätze, ja,
das bist du auch, das bist du auch und gerade die, die da besonders drauf rumreiten, dort
ist es besonders extrem, ja. Leute, irgendwann, wenn ich dann woanders arbeite und auch ein
bisschen danach, dann erzähle ich euch mal, wo ich aktuell gerade bin, bzw. nicht direkt,
wo ich gerade bin, sondern was die dort für merkwürdige Sachen machen, was die dort
für merkwürdige Sachen machen, das Sache ist halt die, wenn ich euch das erzähle, könnt
ihr danach googlen und wahrscheinlich findet ihr dann auch die Firma, wo ich gerade bin,
deswegen, das mache ich erst, wenn ich woanders bin und dann auch erst nach einer Weile, dann
erzähle ich euch mal ein paar Sachen, das sind schon wirklich sehr, sehr weirdchampige
Sachen dabei. Ja, gut.
Weißt ihr, was es bei uns halt auch immer gibt, das muss ich ja mal kurz einwerfen,
bei uns gibt es immer Veranstaltungen, wo dann neue Strategien präsentiert werden oder
so, wo dann, wo dann versucht, irgendjemand die Leute auf das aktuelle Jahr so einzuschwören
und sowas und das ist halt witzigerweise so, dass diese Veranstaltung so Klatsch, so Klatschzwang
herrscht irgendwie, also ok, ich muss, ich muss es nicht beschreiben, es gibt zum Beispiel,
es gibt zum Beispiel einmal im Jahr so einen Kickoff Anfang des Jahres, wo dann der Chef
von der IT und irgendwie der Chef von der, von der Entwicklung und so, keine Ahnung,
wo dann so 5, 5 höhere Führungskräfte dastehen und auf der Bühne erklären, was so Geiles
passiert ist letztes Jahr und was so Geiles passiert wird dieses Jahr, also das ist so,
so, das haben wir öfters mal, also einmal im Jahr und das läuft dann ungefähr so, das
läuft dann ungefähr so, da wird dann erzählt, 2021 war das erfolgreichste Jahr in der Geschichte
und dann alle Leute, so, klatschen, klatschen und ich hab das Gefühl, die setzen da ins Publikum
schon immer Leute, die anfangen zu klatschen, weil keiner freiwillig anfängt zu klatschen,
zumindest wird, wird geklappt, so, 2021 war das erfolgreichste Jahr überhaupt, wir haben
wieder unglaublich viel geleistet und das wäre ohne sie alle nicht möglich gewesen,
deswegen applaudiert euch doch mal selbst und das ist, Leute, ihr glaubt, das ist jetzt
übertrieben, aber nein, das ist nicht übertrieben, die Leute klatschen nach jedem Satz und ich
denk mir mal, Alter, was ist mit euch los, die haben doch überhaupt nichts gesagt und
ihr seid wie verrückt schon am klatschen die ganze Zeit, man, die klatschen wirklich
nach jedem Satz hier oder jedem zweiten Satz wird da geklatscht und ich denk mir so, warum,
wegen was, es kam doch noch gar nichts, es war doch gar nichts spannendes zu erzählen
und dann wird dann immer erzählt, so nach dem Motto, das kann ich jetzt so im Detail nicht
erzählen.
Im Prinzip erzählen sie eh immer das gleiche, dann wird dann irgendwie der Gründer mal zitiert
und dann irgendwelche anderen schlauen, im Prinzip sind diese Reden mehr oder weniger
immer das gleiche und wir sind überall die Besten und haben überall super Ergebnisse
und was auch immer und sonst wird nach jedem Satz geklatscht, Alter und ich glaube, die
haben da wirklich so Paid Actors, die haben da wirklich im Publikum Leute sitzen, denen
sie erzählt haben, klatscht jetzt mal, kann natürlich auch sein, dass die einfach von
einer Marketing Abteilung sind oder irgendwelche anderen, weiß weiß ich, besonders, engagete
Leute, die klatschen wirklich bei jedem Satz, ich denk mir auch mal, was ist das für eine
bescheuerte Veranstaltung?
So, next.
Die Machbarkeit in unterschiedlichen Branchen angeht und wie sich das auf die Wirtschaft
und die ganze Gesellschaft auswirken wird, die haben sich laut einer Umfrage die Viertagewoche
gewünscht, ich auch, ich auch, ich mach die Viertagewoche schon, aber von der Politik
ist bisher jetzt noch keine Rede von einer gesetzlichen Einführung der Viertagewoche,
ihr könnt ja mal schreiben, wie ihr das ganze seht, also findet ihr eine Viertagewoche gut
oder glaubt ihr das funktioniert nicht, schreibt das gerne mal in die Kommentare, das funktioniert,
ich weiß, dass das funktioniert, weil ich mach das schon, das schreibe ich jetzt unter
das Video, bin ich irgendwo eingeloggt, mal kurz checken, ob ich irgendwo eingeloggt bin,
log in, okay, log in, off, YouTube, log in, nein.
Jetzt muss ich erst mal zwei Fakta-Organifizierungen auf YouTube noch machen, dass ich dann einen
Comment drunter schreiben kann, okay, Kommentar, muss ich mal drunter schreiben, so, schreibt
da jetzt drunter, klar funktioniert Viertagewoche, macht das selbst seit 10 Jahren.
Commentieren, bäm, hat das jetzt funktioniert, hat das jetzt funktioniert, ist mein Comment
da, ah, da ist es, so, nice, wir haben tatsächlich mal was kommentiert, ich glaub, das ist das
Premiere, das ich einen YouTube-Comment geschrieben hab, also hier im Stream, so, hab ich irgendwas
überlesen, Chat, dein Jahresgespräch lief kurz zusammengefasst, so, Fullbird Gaming,
dankeschön, fünf Leute, nice, ja, wir wollen auch anerkennen in Form von Gehalt weiter,
ja, ja, bla, bla, bla, so sagt jemand, ja, wir wollen und wir haben das vor und so, aber
wir machen es nicht, ne, du bekommst fünf Prozent mehr Gehalt, das, ach, naja, gut,
immerhin, hey, sie könnten euch auch nix geben, das macht für dich 150, was, 150 Euro im
Jahr, fünf Prozent, äh, das ist aber wenig, ähm, das ist doch wirklich nett von einen,
ja, ja, also, bei uns ist es jetzt so, da muss man tatsächlich sagen, sie haben das,
sie haben das geschickt, geschickt gebaitet, muss man sagen, es gibt ja dieses Jahr den,
also, diesen Inflationsausgleich, den Arbeitgeber bezahlen können, wo du dann auch keine Steuern
oder irgendwie weniger Steuern oder wie auch immer drauf bezahlen musst, Stream ist abgekackt,
oh, ja, gestern bist du über Vodafone, ich hatte richtige Probleme, gestern richtige
Probleme, was Vodafone angehen, äh, Vodafone angehen, eins und eins, ja, okay, das ist
ein Telekom Resale wahrscheinlich, ja, Subscriptions auf YouTube helfen mir immer, vor allem im
YouTube Algorithmus, ja, also, was wollte ich jetzt sagen, ähm, ach, im Monat, ja, okay,
na, 150 Euro im Monat, ich mein jetzt schon mal besser als nix, zumindest, man kann jetzt
ja diesen Inflationsausgleich bezahlen und, äh, finde ich gut, macht mein Arbeitgeber
auch, gibt extra, extra Money, aber es gibt dieses Jahr keine erfolgsabhängige Prämie,
das ist auch witzig, sie haben sich wieder super selbst gefeiert, dass es das geilste
Jahr ever war, so nach dem Motto, also, nein, nicht das geilste Jahr ever, aber ein super
erfolgreiches Jahr und sowas, aber man hätte sein eigenes Ziel trotzdem verfehlt, und man
denkt, hä, wie, das passt doch nicht zusammen, wie kann das super erfolgreich sein, wenn
man sein Ziel verfehlt hat, aber, es gibt jetzt ja den Inflationsausgleich, also das heißt,
im Endeffekt, man hat auf der einen Seite ein bisschen was eingespart, dadurch, dass
man keinen Erfolgsbonus bezahlt, auf der anderen Seite gibt man massig mehr Geld aus, durch
den Inflationsausgleich, aber unterm Strich natürlich mehr Geld, als es durch den, dass
der Inflationsausgleich ist mehr, als es durch den Bonus gegeben hätte, ich sag nicht, wo
ich bin, vielleicht, wenn ich, wenn ich gewechselt hab, achso, ne, du meinst hier, du meinst
den Anbieter.
Ja, das find ich cool, das hab ich von ein paar Leuten schon gehört, dass sie wegen
mir Fachinformatiker-Ausbildung gemacht haben, oder, manche, manche haben ja auch Informatik
studiert, das war nie meine Absicht, muss ich sagen, also ich hab nie wirklich die Videos
gemacht, weil ich mir gedacht hab, Alter, das inspiriert jetzt total viele Leute, das
zu machen, aber, weiß ich, irgendwie, so im Nachhinein find ich trotzdem cool, dass das
bei vielen geholfen hat, ich hab das eigentlich gemacht für die Leute, die damals in der
ähnlichen Situation sind, also die auch Probleme mit der IHK hatten, oder Probleme, äh, während
der Ausbildung hab ich ein bisschen was drüber erzählt, aber es hat anscheinend auch viele
Leute damals inspiriert zu sagen, hey, ich will auch so was machen, das find ich schon
cool, danke schön für den Sub.
Poggers, das kann ich bloß sagen.
Übrigens, wo wir gerade dabei sind, falls ihr, ich kann keinen guten Sellout, das wisst
ihr Leute, ja, ich bin nicht der beste Sellout, aber ich wollte an der Stelle bloß mal sagen,
lasst euren Prime-Sub nicht verfallen, falls ihr einen Prime-Sub habt, weil ansonsten überweist
ihr direkt an Besus 2,50 Euro, so, was gucken wir uns denn als nächstes an?
Händchen, danke schön für den Sub.
Deine offenen Subs, was sind denn offene Subs, Prime und Rein, so muss das sein, Poggers.
Ich muss öfter Sellout machen, Leute, das zieht jedes Mal, ach, Tabs, ach, Tabs, ja,
das stimmt, äh, übrigens, offene Tabs, hier, ich hab noch mehr, da hab ich offene Tabs,
da hab ich offene Tabs, da hab ich ein paar Tabs, leider hab ich mein Desktop mittlerweile
aufgeräumt, mein Desktop hatten die Leute auch immer toll, ich hab jetzt alles in diesen
Ordner geschoben, was ich vorher auf dem Desktop hatte, das war vorher alles da drauf,
war schön voll, das hat die Leute auch immer getriggert, mittlerweile blickt man da wieder
halbwegs durch, was ist denn hier los, Leute, jetzt geht's aber rund, Händchen, danke
schön, Pepo Ransky, Leiterquerschnitt, sehr guter Name, Leiterquerschnitt, ja, ich hab
mich letztens tatsächlich gefragt, wenn ich meinen Motor anschließe, also mein Hof, ähm,
also das Hoftor, den Motor anschließe, das ist 24 Volt DC, mit bis zu, ich glaub, 8 Ampere,
und da war ich am überlegen, was ich da für einen Leiterquerschnitt brauche, was ich dort,
was ich dort, ähm, hinlegen muss, was für einen Leiterquerschnitt brauche ich da, vielleicht
weiß es Leiterquerschnitt, ja, Gartenkralle, danke schön für den Prime Sub, Paul B, 1997
sogar, zwei Monate, Massive Sub, danke schön, Rosario, danke für den Sub, Phantom Tomate,
ne, Phantomate, nicht Phantom Tomate, danke schön für den Sub, du hattest mal so eine
Flash-Animation gezeigt, da war so ein knallbuntes Anime-Linux, wie hieß das, Aya, du meinst
das hier, Aya-Ya-Time, wow, was ist das, eh, Doppelpunktwechsel-VMS, was ist hier los,
ah, das Log-File, was auch immer das da macht, da war ich nix zu suchen, aha, du meinst das
hier oder, Aya-Ya, Aya-Ya, weißt du das hier, ja, 8, 8, 8, 8, 8, 8, 8, 8, 8, 8, 8, 8, 8, 8,
8, 24 Volt, maximal 8 Ampere, das hier, das ist Moe Ubuntu, das ist irgendwie ein Gnome,
Ubuntu Gnome-Skin, gut, genug, genug, Weeps, Weeps in, jetzt sind alle Weeps in, jetzt
kann man ausmachen, ne, welchen soll ich denn davon machen, da gibt es noch mehrere, oder,
das da, ne, oder, wo ist denn der, wo ist denn der aktuelle, GitHub, 2022, ach ne, auf GitHub
gibt es die Lösungsstimme, so, oh, das ist Sixheader-Time, ne, habe ich nicht gemacht,
aber wir könnten uns das, ich bookbanken mir das mal, wenn ich sonst nichts zu tun habe,
können wir uns da was überlegen, welche Editor unter Windows ist der beste, ganz ehrlich,
ich würde überall Wishlist Studio Code verwenden mittlerweile, auch dank der Erweiterbarkeit,
AlphRolf, Dankeschön für den Sub, Abo-Falle zugeschlagen, Pech gehabt, ne, habe ich nicht,
wenn wir schon mal im Thema auf FM sind, ich hab mir meine Arch-By-The-Way-E3 vor allem
seit Wochen mittlerweile ein Problem, glaubst du, du hättest kurz Lust und Zeit, ähm, schreib
einfach mal, sowas darfst du mich nicht fragen, weil ich kann mich dann einfach rausreden,
ich hab keine Zeit, ich hab auch keine Lust, aber schreib einfach mal, Fleet ausprobiert,
weiß ich aktuell nicht, wozu ich das weiß, 1 bis 1,5, sind das diese normalen dicken
Stromkabel, die man auch verwendet für Steckdosen, also dort wo meistens vier oder fünf Adern
in einem Kabel drin sind, Browser-Plinking-Issue, Browser-Plinking-Issue in Arsch, achso, ganz
einfach, kann ich dir sagen, wie das funktioniert, äh, kann ich dir sagen, woran das liegt,
du musst Hardware-Beschleunigung ausschalten, das hatte ich auch, du musst Hardware-Beschleunigung
ausmachen, dann gehts, das gleiche Problem hatte ich auch, guck, und es ist nur Firefox,
ne, Chrome ist es nicht, es ist nur in Firefox so, stimmts, aus Hardware-Beschleunigung,
genau das gleiche hatte ich auch, ich zeig dir wo das geht, warte mal, used browsers when
this problem occured, Brave, Chrome, Firefox, ne, in Chrome hatte ich nix, also in Chrome
hatte ich nix, du kannst, Alter, jetzt brauchst du wieder drei Stunden bis gestartet ist CacWade,
ja, das sind zwei komplett unterschiedliche Paar Schuhe, also VMs, ob das jetzt in Proxbox
ist oder nicht, hat damit nix zu tun, VMs sind VMs und Container sind Container, Container
heißt ein blödes Wort, weil Container irgendwie so sich für viele Leute ein bisschen nach
VM anhört, ähm, Container sind im Prinzip einfach ganz normale Prozesse in das, Alter,
was will dieses Ding von mir, Prozesse die ein bisschen Sandbox sind, aber im Hostkernel
laufen, wie jeder andere Prozess den du startest auch, und VMs sind quasi komplett simulierte,
bis auf die CPU simulierte Hardware und Storage, also im Prinzip das was der Name sagt eigentlich,
so, du musst auf Settings, dann musst du auf GPU glaube ich, ne, ähm, oder Hardware,
ja, und dann musst du das hier ausschalten, use recommended Performance Settings musst
du ausschalten und use Hardware Acceleration musst du ausmachen, hat bestimmt ein paar
Nachteile, aber seitdem hab ich das Problem nicht mehr, ansonsten hat es immer hier überlagert
wenn ich, wenn ich, äh, rumgeswitcht habe, musst einfach ausschalten und dann gehts,
zumindest war es bei mir so, und ich bin da auch nur drauf gekommen, weil irgendjemand
im Chat meinte, probier das doch mal aus, also wo wir wieder dabei sind, absolute next
level high IQ, 5 head Chat, Def Operator, eigentlich schon für den Sub, MI LXC und
Vm in Proxmox, ja gut, und das ist ja die Frage eigentlich, Vm oder Container, ich
hab ehrlich gesagt Proxmox zu wenig verwendet, dass ich jetzt genau wüsste wie man da was
wie handelt, also, weiß nicht, also ich mein der Unterschied zwischen Vm und Container
hab ich ja grad so kurz wie möglich erklärt, aber wie das Proxmox Handling ist, ich geh
mal davon aus, dass das Handling gar nicht so großartig unterschiedlich ist, weil das
ist ja der Grund warum man so nen Frontend verwendet, dass man sich nicht so sehr darüber
Gedanken machen muss.
Es war Gleichstrom, 24 Volt Gleichstrom, GachiBuzz, hab ich euch eigentlich schon die neuen Emotes
gezeigt, die es bald geben wird, ja hab ich, aber da waren glaub ich noch nicht so viele
da gestern, ich zeig euch, ich zeig es euch noch mal kurz, Twitter, Sekunde, ja, ja, ich
zeig euch, ist, ist aber muss man sageniu nur der erste Entwurf, da wird sich ein bisschen
was dran ändern so ersten Entwurf, also der Keks hier der cute Keks kriegt noch blonde
Und der hier kriegt die Bettdecke oben drüber, weil das ist Boomer müde, Boomer schlafend,
Bettge, wupp Bettge, der kriegt die Decke hier so oben drüber, hier so und der ist
gut, Pepo fett, wobei ich sagen muss, wenn man das in klein macht, wenn man das in klein
macht, sieht es aus als hat er tippen, so ungefähr in dieser Größe sind ja dann Emoats, das sieht
aus als hat er tippen der Keks, wenn die klein sind die Emoats, Uber und der kriegt noch so
blonde Haare und muss doch ein bisschen mehr excited gucken, hast du da für einen Designer?
Ja, das ist auch die gleiche, die die alten Emoats gemacht hat, außer die die der Chain
Lore gemacht hat, aber die ganzen Hi-Rez Kekse, das ist die gleiche, die auch die letzten
gemacht hat, ich würde euch jetzt eigentlich das zeigen auf Twitter, aber ich weiß es
gar nicht, mal kurz gucken ob ich es irgendwie finde, Rin, Rin oder irgendwie so Hasty, mit
H, ich weiß es nicht, ich kann es euch gerade nicht zeigen und Werbung machen, erinnert
mich mal dran, ich suche das mal raus, dann kann ich nächstes mal ein bisschen Werbung
machen, für die Emoat Designerin, nee keine Ahnung, keine Ahnung, finde ich jetzt gerade
nicht, ich hatte ich hatte schon mal auf Twitter erwähnt, das habe ich gerade gesucht, aber
auf Twitter findet man ja irgendwie prinzipiell nichts, hätte ich es mal zeigen können, weil
die sucht wahrscheinlich weiterhin nach Aufträgen, also könnte man ja mal Shoutouten, das war
sogar vorher schon kacke die Twittersuche, letztes Video war nice, Pog, finde es toll
dass ihr euch abgenommen habt, ich auch, wie lang sind die Leitungen, 4-5 Meter, Fiesi-Ausbildung
verkürzen, hat jemand Erfahrung gemacht beziehungsweise Stress, ich habe sehr guten Schnitt, ehrlich
gesagt, ich habe meine Ausbildung nicht verkürzt, weil ich faul bin und dachte ich kann noch
ein halbes Jahr lange rumgammeln, kein Witz, das ist wirklich der Grund gewesen warum ich
die Ausbildung nicht verkürzt habe, man könnte auch sagen man könnte noch ein halbes Jahr
was lernen, aber ich habe es für nicht, ich habe nicht verkürzt weil ich faul war, was
hältst du von Rainbow Six Siege, wie findest du die Erinnerung, Rainbow Six Siege ist glaube
ich eines der Spiele wo ich mich am meisten ins Klo gegriffen habe bei Release, von meiner
Einschätzung her in den letzten Jahren, ich habe ja mittlerweile eine ganz gute Quote,
wenn Games rauskommen zu sagen, das wird was, das wird nichts oder teilweise schon von Anfang
an das wird nichts, bei Rainbow Six habe ich verkackt, bei Rainbow Six habe ich gesagt,
meine Güte, wie kann man so verkacken, das Spiel ist dead nach einem halben Jahr, war
nicht so, ich weiß okay der Release war auch wirklich alles andere als geschmeidig, aber
da habe ich wirklich ins Klo gegriffen was meine Prediction angeht, aber ich spiele
es nicht, ich habe keine Ahnung was es für Änderungen gibt, das einzige was ich mir
in den letzten Jahren angeguckt habe war ein paar E-Sport Turniere und da habe ich nicht
durchgeblickt was passiert, ja in der Berufsschule gute Noten haben ist auch nicht sonderlich
schwierig, Berufsschule ist einfach as fuck, also ich hatte auch fast nur einen in der
Berufsschule, sogar in Sport stellt euch mal vor, na gut du wirst ja nicht für sportliche
Leistung bezahlt, sondern eher für Anwesenheit, aber trotzdem, ich hatte fast überall einen,
also Berufsschule war wirklich super easy, das sind Millimeter oder, weil Zentimeter
wäre ganz schön fettes Kabel, ich zeige, okay chat, das muss ich nämlich wissen für
den Motor für meine Hoftor, das muss ich euch fragen, und wenn mein Haus abfackelt
sage ich, ihr müsst es jetzt bezahlen, weil ihr habt mir das falsche empfohlen, ich muss
mal kurz raussuchen, ich habe zwei Rollen Kabel hier, so einmal habe ich das hier da,
Amazon, Sekunde, jetzt ist mein Handy fast runtergefallen, MonkaS, so was hier in der
Richtung habe ich da, sowas, geht das dafür, ja oder, das ist doch das gleiche was man auch
für Steckdosen benutzt oder, ne, nicht dass man so für Steckdosen verwendet, zu dünn,
ne, das ist zu dünn, ist das nicht das exakt gleiche was man auch für Steckdosen verwendet,
Aha, Gleichsturm, das heißt man braucht bei Gleichsturm dickere Kabel, wirklich, da ist
es nicht, ich weiß nicht, nicht dass ich jetzt Mist erzählt habe, Moment, ne, wir gucken
mal ins Handbuch, wie viel das wirklich, wie viel das wirklich braucht, so Handbuch, technische
Daten, also hier, ja super und, es stand da im Handbuch was, das habe ich gesehen, wo
steht das, die 240, die 220, 230 Volt AC, das ist der Input von dem, von diesem Schaltkasten,
mir geht es halt die Kabel die zum Motor müssen, das ist 24 Volt DC, stand ja auch da, so und
da stand jetzt irgendwo was von, wo sieht man dann sowas hier jetzt, ich hab das irgendwo
gefunden im Handbuch, Anschlussplan, Verdrahtungsplan, Chat, wo soll ich gucken, ihr kennt euch damit
doch aus, hier technische Daten, da, da, hier, guck mal da steht es irgendwo, also das ist
egal, das ist egal, ne, ne, ne, ne, ne, 0,8 von 203, wo, wo, wo ist denn hier, wo steht
der was von, wo, wo steht das denn jetzt mit 24 hier, so der Pepega Handbuch, man, Verdrahtungsplan,
Verdrahtungsplan, genau hier kommt, also der Motor kommt ja hier an die 224 Volt Klemmen
dran, aber man weiß nicht, wieviel das da drüber zieht, also wieviel, wieviel Ampere
da drüber gehen, sehe ich jetzt, sehe ich jetzt nichts, ich bilde mir ein, ich hab 8
gelesen, aber das kann doch auch sogar ungefähr sein, guck mal, maximal 140 Watt, was ist
dann 24 mal 8, ok, vielleicht ist es auch mal 6, ok, dann sind es eher 6 Ampere, würde
ich mal sagen, also maximal 6 Ampere, also maximal Leistungsaufnahme je Flügel, das
ist dann quasi 24 Volt, aber je Flügel, je Flügel, ah gut, es geht ja dann über
zwei verschiedene Kabel, also eher 6, 6 Ampere, nicht 8, maximal, ja, eher weniger, ja das
wird schon passen, weg, gut, gucken wir uns mal was neues an, wie lang wird das Kabel,
ja so 4, 5 Meter, im Keller ist die Box mit der Steuerung und allem und der Motor ist
dann halt am Hoftor, das heißt ich muss einmal direkt an der Wand zum Hoftor auf die eine
Seite und dann halt quasi irgendwie 4 Meter unter den Platten im Hof, 4 Meter durch auf
die andere Seite an den Motor, also 1 ist keine Ahnung, 2 Meter lang und 1 ist 5 Meter lang
oder so. Hast du in deinem Vorstellungsgespräch was programmieren müssen oder machen das
nur die großen Tech Firmen, das machen vor allem Firmen, die Leute suchen als Softwareentwickler,
ich bin ja da nicht als Softwareentwickler eingestellt, klar, kannst du das bei anderen
auch machen, aber ich arbeite ja nicht als Softwareentwickler, also so ein bisschen löchern
die Leute mit wie würden sie was machen, also ich kann nicht mehr sagen wie ich das
machen würde, würde ich schon, ob man jetzt die Leute als nur nach 15 Klitsche den Binary
Tree inverten lassen muss, an der Tafel lasse ich mal dahingestellt, schaust du Serien,
ja ab und zu. Ich habe letztens geguckt bei Amazon, wie ist das The Peripheral oder so,
fand ich echt enttäuschend. Also die erste Hälfte fand ich gut, danach war es irgendwie
sehr, naja, man hatte wieder das Gefühl, dass sie irgendeine Hauptfigur entworfen haben,
die einfach alles kann, obwohl es viel bessere Möglichkeiten gegeben hätte, also ich weiß
nicht, irgendwie fand ich es dann sehr uninspiriert so nach der Hälfte, ansonsten mag ich ja
so ein bisschen Science Fiction Kram, aber weiß nicht, das hat mir irgendwie nicht so
zugesagt, vor allem war auch wieder massig unlogisches Zeug drinnen, wo man sich denkt
so ey, wie können die, ich sage das jetzt ohne zu spoilern, wie können die sich kloppen
in dem Hauptquartier von einer super High Security Firma und keine Sicherheitsleute
sind da, wo man sich denkt, hä vorher erzählen sie wie krass bewacht das ist und dann taucht
ich einen Sicherheits Typ auf, naja gut, wie das jetzt gerade heißt, das ist Mario Kart
Double Dash, das Wario Kolosseum, wir hatten Sport in der Berufsschule, ja korrekt, das
ist auch das wichtigste, was man in der Berufsschule machen kann, Leute ohne Scheiß, ich habe
es schon oft genug gesagt, aber überlegt euch mal, stellt euch mal die Frage, jemand
der wirklich die Ausbildung macht, drei Jahre lang und dann eine Prüfung schreibt versus
jemand der die Ausbildung nicht gemacht hat und sich ein halbes Jahr lang auf die Prüfung
vorbereitet hat, was meint ihr wer besser abschneiden wird und das ist aus meiner Sicht
ganz klar der Typ der die Ausbildung nicht gemacht hat, keine Ahnung hat, aber sich
ein halbes Jahr auf die Prüfung vorbereitet hat, das heißt Prüfungsvorbereitung ist das
wichtigste, weil die Art wie die IHK Fragen stellt und auch was die genau an Antworten
hören wollen ist so eine ganz spezielle Art, die hat mit der täglichen Arbeit oder dem
späteren Beruf nichts, wirklich gar nichts zu tun, das ist komplett realitätsfern,
ich habe keine Ahnung warum die sich für dieses Ausbildungsformat so abfeiern, aber
man muss für die Prüfung lernen, man lernt tatsächlich für die Prüfung und nicht irgendwie
für den Beruf, was ist denn das für eine geile Taktik, wir mussten in Sport irgendwas
aufschreiben, was wir in der Freizeit für den Sportmann haben, geile Taktik, quasi
Theorie in Sport, wir machen keinen Sport, wir überlegen uns was man an Sport machen
könnte, auch gute Taktik, Religion in der Berufsschule hatten wir tatsächlich auch,
wir hatten glaube ich irgendwie zwei Stunden Ethik oder Religion oder wie auch immer es
genau hieß damals, das war ja noch 2007 und zwei Stunden hatten wir das, danach war die
Lehrerin krank für die restlichen drei Jahre und hatten es nie wieder und die haben dann
gesagt ja es kriegen alle eine zwei und wisst ihr was, ich war damit nicht einverstanden
dass alle eine zwei kriegen, die haben gesagt alle kriegen eine zwei so nach dem Motto ja
da kann sich keiner beschweren aber ich habe gesagt ich bin damit nicht einverstanden,
wisst ihr warum ich gesagt habe ich bin damit nicht einverstanden, weil ich fast überall
einser hatte und eine zwei für zwei Stunden in der nichts passiert ist fand ich nicht
gut, ich habe gesagt entweder lasst ihr das komplett raus, dann geht ihr in die Statistik
ein oder ihr gebt alle eine eins, aber da haben sie sich nicht drauf eingelassen, ja
mein Durchschnitt war schlechter durch die zwei, muss man sich mal vorstellen, so easy
war die Berufsschule, mein Durchschnitt wurde schlechter, dadurch das ist eine Zweigabe
in Ethik, die hätten das einfach rauslassen sollen, einfach keine Note vergeben, das
ist kein Flex, das ist Berufsschule, Berufsschule ist easy as fuck
Das Ding regelt das intern, das ist korrekt, aber ich brauche trotzdem Kabel vom Kasten
an den Motor und darum geht es ja, ich muss 230 Volt an den Verteilerkasten von dem Motor
anschließen, aber auf der anderen Seite brauche ich noch ein Kabel was zum Motor geht, wie
sieht das aus, was sind typische Programmieraufgaben für ein Vorstellungsgespräch, ich bin bald
mit dem Schul, also ganz ehrlich, ich habe noch nie in einem Vorstellungsgespräch als
Entwickler geführt, das mit dem Binary Tree Inverten ist natürlich gemieme, auch ein
bisschen von YouTube, so nach dem Motto erstmal eine Tafel Binary Tree Inverten, also was
ich erwarten würde in einem Vorstellungsgespräch für einen Entwickler, ich würde mich erstmal
ein bisschen mit ihm über die Technologien unterhalten, was man so einsetzt, was er denn
dazu, was er davon kennt, was er dazu sagt und ich würde ihn wahrscheinlich eher nach
seinen Ansätzen fragen, so nach dem Motto, wir wollen Web Service entwickeln, ein Microservice,
das und das, so und so sehen die Rahmenbedingungen aus, wie würden sie das angehen, dann würde
ich mir von dem ein bisschen erklären lassen, was er machen würde, so nach dem Motto ja,
Message Queue dahin, Asynchron Verarbeitung, wie auch immer, also ich würde mir eher von
dem erklären lassen, wie er Sachen umsetzen würde, weniger ehrlich gesagt, schreiben sie
mal eine Vorschleife auf die Tafel, man so simple Sachen kann man auch machen, vielleicht
wenn man ein bisschen ausfiltern will, weil es gibt ja nach wie vor genug Leute, die sich
auf Positionen bewerben, die von Tuten und Blasen wirklich gar keine Ahnung haben, so
nach dem Motto, ich bin jetzt VMWare Experte, weil ich mal Ubuntu in der VM installiert
habe, vielleicht so die kleinen, so paar kleine, so paar kleine, simple Sachen könnte man
machen, ja zum Beispiel irgendwie, wenn man als objektorientiertes testen will, so entwerfen
sie eine Base Klasse für ein Kartenspiel oder sowas zum Beispiel, das könnte man machen,
das glaube ich auch relativ beliebt, dass du dann irgendwie so eine Klasse machst, so
eine abstrakte Klasse Karte und dann machst du halt weitere Klassen für den jeweiligen
Typ, es ist nichts kompliziert, also so würde ich das machen, ich habe keine Ahnung, ich
habe mich noch nie als Entwickler irgendwo beworben, so würde ich das machen, dass man
vielleicht mal die Leute, die gar keinen Plan haben, ausfiltern kann und den Rest würde
ich sie einfach nur fragen, wie sie spezielle Sachen umsetzen würden, um ein Gefühl dafür
zu kriegen, was die Leute, wie die sich das so denken, ansonsten, keine Ahnung.
Ja, das ist das gleiche, dass zwei Frauen das Kind auch in 4,5 Monaten kriegen, was ja
obviously funktioniert. Steht eben zugelassener Kabelquerschnitt, der Kabeleinführung 1,5-2,5mm,
aha, alles klar. Na gut, kleinere Kabelquerschnitte sind ja dann oftmals eh irgendwelche Litzen
oder so, da kann ich eine Art Endhülse draufkrimpen. Ihr habt genug Leute in der Klasse, die auch
eine 4 oder 5 bekommen haben, also Leute, wie man in der Berufsschule eine 4 oder 5 bekommen
kann, ist mir unbegreiflich, wir hatten auch jemand in der Berufsschule, der hatte geschafft,
das habe ich glaube ich schon mal erzählt, der hat es geschafft, 2 von 100 Punkten zu
schreiben in der Programmieraufgabe, also Programmierarbeit. Und wisst ihr wofür die
zwei Punkte bekommen hat? Weil er zweimal Create Table geschrieben hat. Gab es 2 von
100 Punkten, easy. Rest war anscheinend so unbrauchbar. Alter, 2 von 100 Punkten, das musste er erst
mal schaffen, 0 von 100 Punkten, verstehe ich ja. 0 von 100 Punkten ist, alter leck mich,
ich gebe das einfach leer ab, den Zettel oder schreibe irgendwas drauf. Aber 2 von 100 Punkten,
der hat es versucht, aber komplett versagt. 2 von 100 Punkten mit. Naja, aber ich habe
dann erfahren, nach einer Weile, das war so jemand, der war super nett, aber nie großartig
was erzählt. Aber irgendwann habe ich mal mit ihm ein bisschen geschwätzt und er hat
mir dann erzählt, wie er zu seiner Ausbildung gekommen ist. Und das ist tatsächlich eine
recht tragische Geschichte, er war Steinmetz früher. Wir haben noch keinen Advents-Programm
erstellt gemacht, er war Steinmetz. Und er hatte einen Arbeitsunfall und ist eine Platte
auf den Fuß gefallen. Und seitdem ist sein Fuß kaputt. Und seitdem kann er eben nicht
mehr den ganzen Tag rumlaufen und kann seinen alten Job nicht mehr ausführen. Und er war
quasi anscheinend Steinmetz, wie sagt man, mit voll dabei, also mit Leib und Seele Steinmetz,
der hatte mit Fachinformatiker nichts am Hut. Der konnte den Beruf nicht mehr machen, weil
er einen Unfall hatte. Und sein damaliger Chef, dort wo der Unfall passiert ist, in dem Betrieb,
der hat ihm quasi über Connections eine Physi-Ausbildung vermittelt. So nach dem Motto, du kannst jetzt
nicht mal Steinmetz sein, wer hat doch Fachinformatiker? Und dann hat er halt die Physi-Ausbildung,
dann hat er halt die Physi-Ausbildung gemacht und das war halt überhaupt gar nicht seine
Welt. Ich hab mich die ganze Zeit immer gefragt, wie ist der Typ denn da hingekommen, der hat
überhaupt keinen Plan. Aber klar, das war echt nicht seine Welt. Der wäre sicherlich
lieber Steinmetz geblieben, kann ich euch sagen. Das war ein echt super netter Kerl.
Der war auch irgendwie in der, frag mich nicht, Junioren, in der deutschen Ruder-Nationalmannschaft
unter 21 oder so. Der war mega sportlich auch und so. Der hat so überhaupt nicht in das
Bild für die meisten Leute in meiner Fachinformatiker-Klasse gepasst, der Kerl. Aber, aber, aber, aber,
als ich dann erfahren hab, wie er da hingekommen ist, klar, ja. Ich musste Rest mit DB-Zugriffen
für Vorstellungsgespräche vorbereiten. Was Rest, Rest, Rest, musstest du selbst Requests
machen oder musstest du den Rest AP basteln? Was würdest du sagen, wie kann ich am leichtesten
die Server meiner Firma dafür nutzen können, um zu weinen? Hast du GPUs drinne? Tja. Ja,
da haben wir also wirklich keine Arbeitsstuhe geholfen, wenn dir so eine Steinplatte auf
dem Fuß fällt. Also das einzige, was ich noch weiß, was auf dem Fuß gefallen ist, was
wirklich wehgetan hat, wenn die Winfecten vom Staubsauger auf einem großen Zehe gefallen
waren, ich kann mich noch daran erinnern.grund, ich weiß know, ich hab den Staubsauger då
metallrohr also staubsauger metallrohr war lehnte an der wand und ich sehe es
auch aus dem augenwinkel dass das umfällt ich denke mir halt nichts bei
denke ich mir halt es fällt um und da ist das rohr halt quasi von der wand umgefallen
also da war der staubsauger aber hinten natürlich auch noch das das der schlauch
dran ist es halt runtergefallen und genau quasi so aus ungefähr eineinhalb
metern wie halt das rohr steht ist mir dann halt auf den großen zege fallen das
metallrohr vom staubsauger und das hat das ist richtig blau geworden rot
geworden das hat zwei wochen wehgetan da kann ich überlegen alter wenn die
erstmal so steinplatte auf den fuß fällt das war ganz andere hausnummer oder
kolleg damals bei mir wo ich noch beim provider gearbeitet habe rechenzentrums
umzug der sich in dl 3 80 dem in dl 3 80 auch in fuß gefallen ist so ein alter
so gen 5 oder so wird das gewesen sein so ja so ein teil so 2h ebm hp kiste so
was in der richtung aber eher gen 6 macht aber kein unterschied sind alles
fette kisten ja so ein teil hier war das ist ihm damals auf den fuß gefallen
das wiegt halt auch voll beladen bestimmt 40 kilo
ja der war der war ein paar wochen krank
hast du dich schon mal mit 3d ja ich habe den 3d drucke
ich habe den 3d drucke ich habe ein e3 mega s oder so den habe ich seit
22 und halb drei jahren ist jetzt sicherlich mal nicht mehr das krasseste
high end modell war es damals auch schon nicht aber für meine zwecke dass ich ab
und zu alle paar monate mal irgendwas kleines drucke ist der voll und ganz
ausreichend ja so ein teil ich habe da auch nichts gemodet dran
das einzige was ich gemacht habe ist ich habe hier unten eine lampe ich habe hier
neben dran so eine led so ein led ring dran gemacht dass es quasi dort immer
beleuchtet wo er gerade ist baust du deine modelle selbst ne ich nehme
eigentlich nur die sachen die es fertig auf singy was gibt
was ist denn mit euch schon wieder los ja da hätte ich jetzt gar nicht dran
gedacht aber chat verfügt wie bei allem über viel erfahrung dem server dem
ging es danach wahrscheinlich noch gut ja
ein riesen drocker nee da habe ich keinen erstmal keinen bedarf dran ich
trug ja meistens nur irgendwelche gehäuse für microcontroller oder sonst
was also super filigrane sachen hatte ich bis jetzt eigentlich noch keinen also
ich drücke auch keine modelle oder sowas
ja ich trug irgendwelche gehäuse für microcontroller oder ich habe auch ich
habe auch mal irgendwie so adapter gedruckt wo man den man dran klipsen kann
oder beispielsweise post image ist es hier zu sehen
das ist mein abgefackelter abgefackelter netz teil ich habe beispielsweise die
halte also die halterung für next point an der wand habe ich auch 3d gedruckt
ja mich mal weiß nicht wo ich die habe ich irgendwo mal hier gepostet war sie
so so winkel wie man wo man regale normalerweise drauf macht halt bloß halt
aus plastik aus dem 3d drucker eine max fps figur würde gut ankommen
ich habe tatsächlich eine 3d gedruckte max fps kicks figur aber die habe ich
nicht selbst gedruckt
man könnte man könnte das als merchandise fast anbieten aber dann
müsste man es halt irgendwo in auftrag geben
aber ich habe mir jetzt erstmal zwei masten bestellt mit kicks aufdruck dass
ich nicht face reveal machen muss während wenn ich mein rechner aufbaue
so also kommt wir gucken was an ich bin jetzt schon zwei stunden an was was
können wir uns noch angucken hier auf auf zwei ist erbärmlich live hacking
fünf angriffe in 30 minuten so videos sind ja meistens entweder richtig
spannend oder eher pains jam aber 30 minuten haben wir okay 44 minuten nice
was haben wir sonst noch selbst cleaning litter box mega test ja das interessiert
mich so selbst eines selbst cleaning litter box habe ich mir auch schon
überlegt zu kaufen die frage ist ob die verwendet also katzen klo quasi selbst
reinigen ist katzen klo lohnt sich das was lohnt sich was verdient eine
erzieherin im kinderheim wahrscheinlich zu wenig wahrscheinlich zu wenig aber
ganz im ernst im leben ist also im leben würde ich das nicht machen
kinder sind mittags nervigste was es gibt und den ganzen tag kinder geschreie
und nervige kinder am start das kann ich mir am besten will nicht vorstellen für
kein geld der welt also deswegen würde ich auch nie lehrer werden oder so was
boah ich weiß ich wieder sebar oder dass das sich vorstellen aber lehrer also
lehrer ist ja schon schlimm kindergarten ist auch schlimm
am schlimmsten dürfte wahrscheinlich so hauptschullehrer oder so was sein oder
generell so lehrer von sagen wir mal so fünfter bis zehnte klasse das ist
glaube ich richtig ab fack dann sind sie nämlich auch so frech alle und facken
dich nur noch ab den ganzen tag du würdest eigentlich am liebsten jedes mal
eine eine runterhauen am liebsten aber darfst du nicht
ja da kommen dann irgendwelche 15 jährigen halbstarken an und meinen sie
sind super schlau und können dich nerven und du kannst nichts dagegen machen außer
blöde sprüche machen genau da du darfst ja nicht einfach eine
runterhauen es geht ja nicht berufsschullehrer ist auch wieder wiederum
so ein ding je nachdem wo ist es halt auch
der in frankfurt muss extra vergütet werden ja
ne aber lehrer würde ich wirklich also ich habe jetzt wirklich größten
respekt für jeden dass ich den scheiß antut
ne aber das ist halt im leben nicht machen
lehrer ist wirklich ganz ganz grausam was haben wir denn trotzdem so leute also wir
haben jetzt die auswahl wollen wir uns wollen wir uns live hacking angucken
oder was eine erzieherin verdient oder die abgründe von link in kommt wir gucken
mal wir gucken mal in das hacker mann video rein
ne wir gucken das hacker mann video rein kratzen klo ja können wir dann aber sind
auch für es auch in 30 minuten video wir gucken mal kurz heckermans rein
schauen wir mal mal gucken mal gucken ob das ein gutes oder jebait jebait ist
alles klar
wirtschaftsinformatik das heißt er kann nicht in beide retri in wörten
wo gehts denn los wo gehts los hier da da gehts los
cringe joke alter ok nachdem das ein vortrag in der schule
ist ist das wahrscheinlich jetzt nicht super krasses high iq zeug ich hoffe ich hoffe es
geht es geht darüber hinaus dass man auf der webseite in die developer tools geht
und dort eine andere zahl einträgt kann mir mal einer erklären was dieses auf
den tisch geklopft eigentlich sein soll ich meine sind die leute zu cool zum
klatschen oder das habe ich in der schule beziehungsweise auch später nie
verstanden warum klopft man auf den tisch dass die sind sich zu die sind zu
geil zum zum klatschen also die finden sich zu toll oder wie klatschen macht
jeder klatschen macht jeder aber klopfen ist nice
kommt aus den unis aber warum ich bin software entwickler und ich bin gründer
von der developer akademie wie gerade schon angekündigt wurde das heißt mein
job ist es quasi quer einsteiger zu gefragten programmieren weiterzubilden
das heißt leute die vielleicht vorher was komplett anderes gemacht haben die
aber sagen programmieren it das hat mir schon immer tiere spaß gemacht ich will
gerne laut genug werden und in die software entwicklung gehen ich denke es
laut genug oder mitgebracht habe sind fünf hackerangriffe aus der praxis
heckermans denn warum mache ich das ganze ist es so wenn man programmierer
werden möchte dann sollte man natürlich auch so die grundlegenden sicherheitslücken
da draußen kennen denn wenn man apps und software programmiert und man macht
vor dem aber schon ein paar videos geguckt daher kommt euch auch bekannt
so eine riesen sicherheitslücke rein dann ist das natürlich nicht so toll und
dementsprechend leute einfach alles in rust placing the fast memory safe egal
ob man sich jetzt mit it security tiefer befassen will oder was ganz anderes
machen will auf jeden fall damit befassen und selbst wenn man jetzt gar
kein programmierer werden will ist es einfach sehr wichtig dass man diese
typischen sicherheitslücken kennt einfach um sich selber zu schützen ganz
konkret machen wir heute fünf attakken aber zuerst habe ich euch einmal dieses
dildje mitgebracht jetzt kommt zuerst einmal haben wir 724 boeing 747 fanhansa
bedeuten hat jemanden die idee also kleiner tipp ja oder da redet schon
jemand
724 stück ja wahrscheinlich weil irgendwie was verbuggt ist bei der
auftragsannahme oder oder es ist eine anzahl genau und eine boeing 747 da
müsste ich einmal nachgucken kostet wie viel über 300 millionen und wenn wir
724 boeing 747 nehmen dann ist das der jährliche schaden der verursacht wird
durch cyberangriffe da draußen das war jetzt eine überleitung woher soll man
das denn anhand dieser zahlen wissen dass er darauf raus will man
online hier was am meisten gehackt wie soll man darauf kommen dass er mit dem
bild darauf raus will jetzt es gibt keine angriffe mehr auf andere systeme als auf
online shops da draußen und kleiner spoiler wir werden heute auch so einen
kleinen online shop auseinandernehmen ja also insgesamt machen wir fünf kleine
attakken heute nummer eins umgehen ich glaube wir alle kennen das wenn man zum
beispiel auf irgendeine zeitung geht und plötzlich geht da so ein ding auf wo
gesagt wird hey du musst erst einmal bezahlen bevor du hier jetzt weiter
kannst da gibt ja da gibt es da gibt es ja meistens schon sogar browser plugins
für allerdings muss man halt auch sagen ich glaube ich glaube die seiten machen
das absichtlich so unter anderem dass suchmaschinen das besser indizieren
können und vielleicht wollen sie auch dass man es umgehen kann in gewisser
weise ich habe da auch keine richtige erklärung für weil man könnte es ja
theoretisch total einfach lösen den content nur ausliefern wenn du
authentifiziert bist und abo hast das ist ja an sich kein problem
das ganze umgehen kann anschließend werden wir so einen kleinen log in
hecken auch etwas dass ich bestimmt fünfmal am tag auf instagram gefragt
werde ob ich für irgendjemanden den log in hacken kann
nein kannst du auf instagram nicht kann ich auch nicht und kann wahrscheinlich
kaum einer weil wenn es wirklich auf instagram system bedingte schwachstellen
gäbe hätten wir wirklich probleme wenn jetzt leute nur 1 2 3 4 5 6 als
passwort verwenden ist es ja keine schwachstelle im instagram log in system
sondern die leute einfach nur kack passwort und keine zwei fakte
identifizierung sage ich hier mal so ein paar kleine tricks wie man da rangehen
könnte anschließend werden wir mal so ein server analysieren und mal schauen
was da so alles drauf läuft was vielleicht nicht jeder sehen sollte und
anschließend werden wir ein paar passwörter knacken und dann wie gesagt
den online shop hecken also ich würde sagen wir fangen direkt an mit der
allerersten attacke und das coole ist keine firmen irgendwie aus der mit
gebracht sei doch so gut dass er fröhlich ist würde ich jetzt nicht als
negativ punkt sehen vielleicht freut er sich einfach dass er das erzählen kann
das wäre auch ein bisschen unfair und vor einigen außerdem hört man noch mit
sicherheit lieber leuten zu die zumindest das ausstrahlen dass sie das
gerne machen als leute die vorne stehen denken sind leute ich habe keinen bock
auf den scheiß hier kommen erste slide zweite slide dritte slide fertig so so
viel besser deswegen unbedingt nur an eurer eigenen software ausprobieren oder
wenn ihr die ausdrückliche erlaubnis hat nicht einfach an irgendwelchen seiten ich
habe alles nach programmiert das heißt immer wenn ich so eine lücke finde dann
code ich das ganze einfach nach und ich habe hier mal so eine typische
nachrichten seite nachgekodet bitte seite freischalt mit zahlen wenn man
irgendein artikel angucken möchte und dann geht erst mal so ein komisches ding
auf als erstes als erstes geht das meiner ds gvo cookie banner auf einloggen oder
hey du musst erst mal bezahlen bevor du weiter kannst
jetzt müssen wir dieses fenster irgendwie weg bekommen damit wir den
inhalt dahinter sehen können okay ich bin jetzt ich bin jetzt enttäuscht wenn
jetzt wirklich nur developer tools aufmachen kommt und set index verändern
oder sowas oder oder dings löschen und und hintergrund overlay weg machen was
könnten wir da machen hat jemand die idee david ja genau man kann nämlich in
einem web browser immer den quellcode sehen und nein ich kann einfach mal hier
rechts klicken und auf untersuchen gehen und dann sieht man hier an der seite den
ganzen quellcode und selbst wenn man jetzt noch nie gecoated hat in seinem
leben kann man trotzdem einigermaßen verstehen was hier steht das heißt hier
steht zum beispiel button und das ding wird hier auch angezeigt und wenn ich
runter gehe steht hier auch button und wenn ich mir so den quellcode angucke
dann sehen wir auch eigentlich ganz genau was man da vielleicht verändern
okay das ist jetzt ein äußerst stark simplifiziertes beispiel könnte damit
der button anklickbar ist sieht jemand hier ein wort kann es auch ein ticken
größer vielleicht machen dann sieht man es vielleicht noch besser was man
vielleicht hier entfernen könnte damit der button anklickbar ist
hat schon die mauszeiger drauf genau hier steht das wort disabled und das coole
ist ich kann das ganze einfach bearbeiten das heißt ich kann da
einfach doppelklick drauf machen ich will jetzt nicht wissen wie viele
der zwölfjährigen in diesem forst also der hat sich der hat sich sehr jung
angehört gerade im hintergrund was ich 12 13 14 also ich will jetzt nicht wissen
wie viel zwölfjährige auf diesem vortrag gesessen haben und sich gedacht
haben leute krasse hacken bei action jetzt habe ich es voll drauf developer tools
aufmachen und jetzt sehen wir dass der weiter warten anklickbar ist das heißt
ich kann jetzt aber umfg und dann sind wir drin und das ist jetzt nichts
sind drin leute endlich so extrem leicht ist und in der praxis kommt das gar
nicht vor ich sehe das jeden tag und ich wette wenn ihr mal so ein zwei
zeitungsseiten einfach mal anguckt werdet ihr aber wie gesagt also es gibt ja
browser plugins für die das mittlerweile schon quasi für dich machen und die
frage ist ja wenn die zeitungsseiten das nicht wollen warum liefern sie dann den
content aus das würde sich ja relativ einfach machen lassen also es wird auf
jeden fall irgendwas mit indizierung von suchmaschinen zu tun haben aber ich
glaube auch und ich weiß nicht warum aber ich bin mir relativ sicher das
machen die absichtlich und ich weiß nicht warum ich weiß nicht warum
aber auf der anderen seite es ist wirklich easy zu fixen
du liebst du lieferst den content einfach nicht aus fertig da kannst du noch so
viel frontend seitlich machen da kannst du dir die seite anzeigen lassen ja aber
dann steht da nichts drauf an der stelle normalerweise was sehen müsstest oder
es steht halt einfach nur x und z abc lorem ipsum dass die seite gefüllt ist
ja genau wie gesagt das zu für zum indizieren und so was ja das können wir
vorstellen ja trotzdem also man lässt sich bekönnen sich das relativ
andere hacken auf dieser seite die könnt ihr euch gerne mal angucken den
link findet ihr in der präsentation kann man das nicht leicht umgehen wenn man
das seite trugt nee die seite wird ja eigentlich so gedruckt videos wie du
siehst jetzt ist natürlich die frage wie können wir das problem lösen weil das
ist ja nicht im sinne des erfinders nur den content ausgehen wenn man auch
anifiziert ist und aber hat hat jemand eine idee ja genau also ganz einfach
gesagt die daten die kommen ja immer vom server und auf den server da kann nicht
unbedingt jeder darauf zugreifen man könnte zum beispiel so eine sperre
chat chat wahrscheinlich ist das glaube ich glaube wir sind nicht die richtige
zielgruppe dafür wollen wir weiter gucken oder was anderes gucken
könnt euch ihr könnt euch überlegen sucht so ich sucht so ich aus skip was
anderes ok
ja wie ich glaube wir sind wir sind nicht die zielgruppe für chat was hat er
denn was was kommt denn was sind denn eigentlich für themen
log in hacken was läuft da ok ganz kurz lasst mal kurz rein rein rein skippen log
log in
ok ok was anderes gut also zeigt mal ja was was was haben wir noch
eigentlich wollte ich das jetzt nicht unbedingt im stream gucken aber ich bin
am überlegen ob ich nicht so selbstreinigungs katzen klo kaufen soll
die frage ist dann ob jikos verwendet
und das ist wiskas liter robot 4 die folgen zu der course liter robot 3
die kammerer fahre ist das die beste selbstkönigungs box an dem markt
wo ich es war eine Frage das ist einfach der chico tritt ja durch wenn sich auf
einmal ihr katzen klo anfängt zu drehen ich meine wenn die raus ist ja und
wichtig ich brauche integration die katze macht das doch nicht selber
wie soll denn die katze das selber machen den katzen klo sauber machen
die series ist ein asmr video single review of a new machine ballooned into a
poop off das ist ganz schön teuer oder das ist ja hier trick 17 was macht die denn da
ich kippe gleich ein bisschen voraus alles die ist ja niedlich
my testing has been beyond so having so many amazing cats is invaluable
erst mal ordentlich kann ein bisschen bisschen farbe wie chico oder guckt mal
guckt guckt euch die mann und guckt euch hier unten schicko an ähnlich
ähnliche farbe nur dass sie die viel mehr weiß hat als chico
by using security cameras on the machines
es war schön das klo gekackt ne bis jetzt nicht mosquito bang bang mein klo
geht weg ok also sprich die meisten dinger machen probleme wenn sie
dauerhaft benutzt werden aber das habe ich mir gedacht ja naja naja also wir
wollen jetzt mal nicht übertreiben wenn du also in der regel sagt man ja eh ein
ein klo ist zu wenig ja also chico hat auch hier im ersten stocken klo und dem
erdgeschossen klo und die benutzt auch beide und wenn man das alle wenn man
das morgens oder oder abends mal sauber macht oder je nachdem wenn ich viel
geschissen ist auch alle zwei tage das reicht ja in der regel also ich meine
es sei denn man hat so eine hyper hyper kacke kacke am kacken ist katze die den
ganzen tag nichts anderes macht als kacken aber also ganz ehrlich
chico schafft es nicht in dem tag beides voll zu kacken das ist auch kein kein
vergleich weil die katz verbuddeln das ja immer du musst einfach nur gucken dass
dein katzen klo eben ordentlich katzenstreutränder dass die in kram
verbuddeln können das macht das macht schiko schon relativ
big brain die fängt in einer ecke an dann wird das verbuddelt und das nächste
mal geht es in die andere ecke
sechs stück ok dann verstehe ich dass er keinen bock hat den katzen klo zu
reinigen weil mit sechs katzen da brauchst du ja da reichen ja zwei klos
nicht da brauchst du ja wahrscheinlich zehn klos und die muss dann auch jeden
tag sauber machen alle zehn die kann halt sechs katzen aber auch den
output hat er nicht angst dass die abhauen
moment wir hatten das intro doch schon ach so das ist ein witz verstehe jetzt
auf geht's testen mal die litterboxes
die schafft das mit dem schaffen gar nicht das wichtigste für mich ist schon
mal home assistant integration dafür ich muss dann auch wissen wie oft es
sauber gemacht wurde am tach und sowas das brauche ich nicht ich habe nur
schicko
ja kickstarter ich sagte selbstreinigende jeans was ist es mit
selbstreinigen sachen dass man gescampt wird auf kickstarter schön in die
kamera
so i backed it and then counted it and backed it counted it about three times
finally opting to just wait for it to be available on amazon which would give me
the confidence i needed to spend that much money on it so that was back in
march and initially i really liked it
pippa please
wow i'm not gonna go into any more depth on this machine as there's a lot to talk
about okay geht das auch ein bisschen zügiger 199 oder so ein fazit oder so
was me you already have the little robot 3 does it offer enough improvements to upgrade okay
it's a unit since may and a production model since the summer so i've given
them a pretty intense road test test the little robot 4 is much sleeker than the
three ich gucke uns das fazit an to cut a very long story short yes the little robot 4 is a worthy upgrade from the
little robot 3 to me little robot 4 was kostet das ding
if you feel that things i've covered in here are of value little robot 4 new little robot 3 that i
would definitely recommend it is a much better machine it is much more robust better made and
has lots more features and is going to have even more features save up the money if your little
robot 3 is working fine you don't need another one and you're happy with it okay es das aber
ganz schön teuer das ist auch der 3er wo ist denn der 4er little robot 4 das ist wieder so
ein kokona kokona only product oder liefern überhaupt nach deutschland mal gucken ob die
noch dort was hallo et hallo et achso tschüss ne was muss ich mal ah das ist aber schlecht
gemacht das ist wirklich schlecht gemacht was kostet er nach deutschland zu verschicken
email address company country ah es geht nur kokona land was gibt es denn was gibt es denn
bei amazon self cleaning litter box tamri china chinesen zeug ist er doch der litter robot das
ist doch alles das gleiche oder das ist das ist quasi reprinted china chinesen zeug ganz
ehrlich schicko verwendet wahrscheinlich ähnlich schicko guckt sich das ding an und denkt sich
warum hast du mein altes klo weggemacht stellen mein altes klo wieder hin schicko hat es nicht
so mit neuen sachen was es so teuer macht ja das wird mich auch mal interessieren was es so teuer
macht bitteschön ich möchte mal zur kaufentscheidung vieler helfen die toilette macht was es verspricht
erspart arbeit bei katzen unter zwei kilogramm reagiert es nicht bei uns geht ich sage nur auf
deutsch aus dem produkt teuer ja trotzdem aber warum muss das so teuer sein ok nee wisst ihr
was ich ich werde mir keine kein selbst reinigen das katzen klo kaufen zumal schickos wahrscheinlich
ähnlich verwenden wird die leute ich sage euch schicken wir aus protest wahrscheinlich neben
dran und sagt macht mein altes klo wieder hin oder oder mauts dann davor mau mau mau was ist denn
hier los sind scheiß klo man stellt das alte wieder hin ich weiß so normales katzen klo
kostet 30 euro und das andere jetzt 700 sogar fast 900 nee das muss nicht sein muss nicht sein
ok dann gucken wir uns jetzt an was eine erzieherin verdient ohne ohne kinderlärm sorry
leute doch wir gucken uns das doch nicht an kann ich mir nicht angucken trich trich durch bei
gleich gleich gleich entfernen die abgründe von linkt in was
david am start wissenschaft wirtschaft linkt in das ist da wo man von irgendwelchen recruit
hat angeschrieben wird für jobs die man sich weder haben will noch sich für eignet
ok komm wir gucken uns jetzt trotzdem an das reicht mal ja
jojo gang david am start hier für euch linkt in ist schon lange nicht mehr nur da um neue jobs
an land zu ziehen und so zu tun als wäre man beruflich wahnsinnig gut vernetzt früher konnte
man noch einfach behaupten was ein neues pc selber macht haben wir nichts bestellt ja ich
bin immer noch am überlegen ob 13.900 k wasserkühlung und halt das riesen fette gehäuse oder vielleicht
nun in 13.700 k luftkühlung und ein bisschen kleineres gehäuse wobei die cpu sich ja nicht
so viel nehmen von der hitzeentwicklung also theoretisch kann ich den großen auch luftkühlen
das macht ja eigentlich nicht so viel es ist halt in benchmarks kacke und beim rendern vielleicht
kacke in games ist es kein thema da kannst du es auch luftkühlen ja sogar der den habe ich
übrigens aktuell im rechner sogar der noctua hat problem es gibt eigentlich so gut wie keine
kühlung die den aktuellen 13.900 k unter volllast wirklich gut kühlen kann egal ob luft egal ob wasser
was du vielleicht machen kannst du so eine custom riesen custom wasserkühlung die kriegst vielleicht
gebacken oder so also ohne power limit ja mit power limit ist kein problem ich weiß nicht
aber ich muss bestellen leute sonst wird das dieses jahr nix mehr
egal wir gucken jetzt die abgründe von linkt an
associate by pretty little marketer und sich für die neue position feiern lassen heute wird man
darauf aufmerksam gemacht dass das ein fehler sei und wird sogar aufgefordert den fehler zu beheben
doch es wird noch viel peinlicher neben überragenden social skills von sensiblen
ceos posten leute wenn sie von vögeln angesteckt warum sollte man das auf linkt in posten warum
will ich mein taubenschiss auf der nase auf linkt ok man oder ihren ersten ich verstehe auch nicht
warum manche leute sachen auf instagram oder warum manche leute tiktok videos für irgendwas machen
aber gut gabelstapler verkauft haben topics dazu wie man dem unternehmen auf geschäftsreisengeld
für essen sparen kann einige nutzen sogar den tod von familien was ist das
i managed to use the coffee machine to cook chicken
was ist mit den leuten los nehmen auf geschäftsreisengeld für essen sparen kann
einige nutzen sogar den tod von familienmitgliedern um das eigene business und die personal brand zu
pushen steigen wir hinab in die abgründe von linkt in der sponsor dieses videos feiert ein
großes comeback blink ist auf blink ist findet ihr zusammenfassungen von über 5000 sachbüchern aus
27 kategorien mit der app könnt ihr euch aber außerdem könnt ihr das aber eine woche lang
wusste gar nicht dass es die noch gibt los test moment blink ist ne ne ne das die einkaufsliste
ich meinte to do list das war so ein ding was microsoft übernommen hat vergangenen sommer
hat dieses bild weltweit für schlagzeilen gesorgt ein weinender ceo zeigt auf linkt in wie elendig
er sich fühlt nachdem er zwei seiner mitarbeiter gefeuert der arme post den er jemals geteilt hat
quince wenn jemand entlassen wird gerade in den usa könnte man schnell denken dass diejenigen die
den job verlieren die leidtragenden sind da immerhin ihre existenz bedroht wird aber dieses gar nicht
gestellte linkt in selfie mit verquollenen augen und sich hart erarbeiteten tränen ist ein wegruf
an uns alle die gefühle der ceos und manager in solch schweren momenten in denen sie über
die schicksale ihrer belegschaft das ist das verwundbarste was er aller Zeiten was er geteilt
hat my fault ey wenn er wenn es seinen fehler ist er könnte doch einfach sagen jungs hat
zu erledigt bleibt doch da wo ist das problem
people first business hyper social
der hätte noch einfach so ok wenn er das nicht will hätte ihm nicht einfach sagen können ok
leute wir können uns noch mal drüber unterhalten wir machen neuen vertrag was auch immer wir lassen
das ganze bleiben bleibt da ich meine wo ist das problem entscheiden sind mindestens genau so
wichtig der typ ist mittlerweile ein richtiger linkt in influencer mit über 40.000 follow an
yes bei linkt gibt es auch follower linkt in influencers wird ja immer schlimmer und vor knapp
zwei monaten hat er noch mal ein rausgehauen er hat einen richtig langen post über den
tod seiner großmutter veröffentlicht in den ersten zwei setzen geht es dann auch tatsächlich
um die großmutter ab dann geht es nur noch um ihn um sein grind lifestyle und er promotet
sein business aber auf linkt gibt es natürlich noch mehr es gibt einen ganzen subreddit mit
dem namen linkt in lunatics zu den auswüchsen auf linkt in massives shout out da ist absolutes
gold bei braden von vorhin ist nicht der einzige manager der etwas realitätsferne wirde ratschläge
gibt dieser dude hat erst mal einen absolut stabilen bad und wer hätte gedacht erst auch
CEO bei einer rasierer firma und er hat wie so viele auf linkt in ein problem mit freizeit
im jungen alter seine message an alle 22 jährigen ist deshalb gut essen fit bleiben aber auch
die 18 stunden arbeitstage für 15 jahre macht du andere business coaches haben noch bessere
ratschläge nach drei wochen urlaub fragen sei keine gute idee dass der firma nämlich zeigen
dass sie auch ohne dich auskommen und deshalb soll man nach weniger fragen motivation auf
linkt in geht aber auch in das ist so los diese ganze manager kacke immer extrem verschwurbelt
die leute leute ganz im ernst die können ruhig in ihrer welt leben ja wie viele das davon
wirklich selber glauben weiß ich nicht viele glauben wahrscheinlich mit zunehmender zeit
auch immer mehr weil es einfach sonst nicht in ihr weltbild reinpasst aber ganz im ernst
sie können machen was sie wollen aber ihr müsst euch immer eine sache überlegen ihr
könnt ihr nicht zwingen dazu sich da irgendwie anders zu verhalten oder etwas anderes zu
wollen aber sie können euch auch nicht zwingen das zu machen und gerade in der it in aktuellen
zeiten es werden an jeder ecke hände ringend tausende zehntausende hunderttausende leute
gesucht ihr findet wahrscheinlich easy was neues mit besseren bedingungen empfiehlt
zu ein link in account ja ja ich habe auch eine link in link in account ja mein link in account
das problem ist nur ich habe den ich habe das password des zugangspasswort vergessen
ich habe kein login mehr für den account den habe ich mit irgendeinem ich habe den
habe ich mit irgendeiner fake email adresse angelegt und habe jetzt kein login mehr ja
silently hier everyone except what is good reject and forget what is not this is intelligent
living good morning was ein büten der mitarbeiter kommentiert daraufhin einfach nur slay einige
manager und startups glänzen auch mit innovativen ideen hier wird beschrieben wie in einem
unternehmen die just eat power hour eingeführt wurde vielen mitarbeitern ist es schwergefallen
mittags zeit weg vom monitor zu verbringen das ist ja auch so schwierig ja so rollt die
firme einfach nicht und deshalb gibt es jetzt die innovative power hour eine stunde für mittag
essen einen kleinen spaziergang okay die leute haben keine zeit für mittagessen deswegen führt
man jetzt mittagessen ein sehe ich das richtig klingt ja logisch man könnte einfach sagen um
elf bis bis bis eins gehen die leute mittagessen also man könnte auch einfach sagen pause oder
worauf auch immer du lust hast den meisten von uns ist dieses neue startup konzept vielleicht
besser bekannt als mittagspause wie viele leute im pr team da wie viele nächte brainstorm mussten
brilliante idee zu kommen es gibt aber auch manager mit noch weniger taktgefühl auf linkedin
while russia is taking over ukraine we're taking over the amazon event industry whoever
can't handle it take shelter dem dudes hätte mal jemand sagen müssen dass er mehr auf seine personal brand geben
muss denn das ist am ende des tages das wichtigste auf linkedin wer 1,2 milliarden im lotto oder
100.000 follower auf linkedin wählen kann nimmt immer die follower da man niemals die power der
personal brand unterschätzen darf ein perfektes beispiel dafür ist mit hier der sich selbst als
personal trainer for your mind bezeichnet er war da bestimmt auch eine telegram gruppe
hachzeit und fünf leute die er noch nie getroffen hat haben ihn gefragt ob er nicht mit von linkedin
sei das dachte er sich dass es ein verrückter zufall sei linkin influencer sohn hat er verstanden
wie powerful es ist sich eine personal brand aufzubauen ja ich auf linkedin gibt es viele
menschen die langfristig so cool und dieses geschwätze man es ist so ätzend er großartig
vernetzt sein wollen wie mitch da gibt es leute die selfies aus dem stau auf dem weg zur arbeit
machen und für ihren job halt auch den busy verkehr inkauf nehmen weil hastag love my job
hastag love my time und hastag mir gern oder workaholics die super unangebrachtes selfies
vom krankenhaus bett warum zum teufel sitzt die im krankenhaus mit ihrem laptop ich mein ey wenn
man dort bei seinen angehörigen sitzen will und den laptop sich mitnimmt weil man im zweifelsfall
halter stundenlang sitzt okay aber würde ich seriously ein ein foto davon machen dass ich
am krankenbett von meinem vater oder so sitze und am arbeiten bin also sich den laptop mitzunehmen
wenn man ganz nach da sitzt ist ja eigentlich nichts dagegen zu sagen aber fotos und dann
irgendwas von der firma zu posten ich weiß nicht des bruders machen und sich bedanken
dass sie remote arbeiten können super super super lustige posts im hochzeitsoutfit weil
clients größer husband es gibt aber das sehe ich auch so auch leute aus der gen z die gleichaltrige
verteufeln weil die gen z eigentlich kein recht darauf hat so was wie eine work life balance zu
fordern weil sie gerade in ihren besten arbeitsjahren sind all diese leute haben ihre
prioritäten natürlich straight da wird halt erst geschaut ob es der schwangeren frau gut geht
das ist der tagesablauf oder was ach nee das ist nur von 6 bis 10 ok was macht er er wacht
auf ertrinkt war ok wasser trinken braucht selbstverständlich einen 15 minütigen eigenen
punkt das ist klar wasser trinken ist es essentiell 15 minuten wasser trinken
36 aber dann erst mal auf link in posten dass er wasser getrunken hat wahrscheinlich ganz furchtbar
wichtig so dann hat er dann hat er noch kurz zeit er muss natürlich selbstverständlich zuerst auf
link in posten um zu gucken wie es einer schmerz bevor er guckt wie seiner schwangeren frau geht
erst mal aufwachen trinken link in post machen und dann gucken wie es der schwangeren frau geht
selbstverständlich wird er hat als seine prioritäten richtig am start
eat a plant based breakfast oh schön gym schauer
na gut
also mal ganz davon abgesehen es gibt bestimmt genug leute die das auch so machen würden aufstehen
erst mal irgendwie social media gucken twitter posten irgendwie posten sonst wie und dann gucken
wie geht es eigentlich meiner frau ganz ehrlich wahrscheinlich wahrscheinlich wahrscheinlich
würde ich auch so machen aber ich würde sich posten ich würde ich würde sich posten mal ganz
davon abgesehen sollte er beim aufwachen nicht neben sich gucken können was seine schwangere frau
gerade oder haben die getrennte schlafzimmer und ob es der schwangeren frau gut geht nachdem das
glas wasser getrunken und auf linkedin gepostet wurde besonders nennenswert in dieser wannabe
außerdem wird die frau im zweifelsfall schon ein link in pn schreiben ja gut geht nachdem das
high performer linkedin bubble ist joshua joshua aus der business class weiß nämlich wie es läuft
weekends are for the week und erst wenn du dein volles potential dieses geschwätze immer mann
zyklisch einkommen fitness und wohlstand hast darfst du das ist ja ein bisschen das was dir bei was
sie die ganzen trainertypen auf youtube auch erzählen wollen immer wir wissen ja du musst
hacheln musste du dir mal frei nehmen da ist er ja da ist dieser post bei linkedin lunatics mehrere
tausend abwärts bekommen hat hat sich joshua dann aber zum glück noch mal zum niederen volk
hinabgelassen und sich aus seinem luxusurlaub gemeldet ein mega cooles piece an all die broke
people mit 0815 jobs die von seinen linkedin posts getriggert werden entweder bist du dumm
arrogant oder einfach nur faul am ende des videos würde ich euch gerne noch die motivierende linkedin
story vom lieben lumko soll wandle vorlesen gestern war ich unterwegs zu einem vorstellungsgespräch an
der straße habe ich einen hungernden hund gesehen ich hielt an um ihn zu füttern und habe das
interview deshalb verpasst am nächsten tag habe ich einen anruf bekommen ich bekam eine zweite
chance für das interview und solle doch vorbeikommen ich war zwar überrascht aber bin hingegangen der
interviewer kam rein es war der hund ich hoffe euch hat diese kleine geschichte gefallen ansonsten
liebe gang feiert gut und case closed alles klar jetzt wissen wir bescheid
jetzt wissen wir bescheid c++ vom scratch ne leute so viel könnt ihr mir gar nicht
subscriben prime abos geben und sonst was dass ich mir jetzt c++ vom scratch angucken werde
amerikaner können mit geld nicht umgehen mal so mal so aber es ist halt bei den amis freedom du
kannst mit deinem geld machen was du willst entweder eine krankenversicherung abschließen
oder nicht und im zweifelsfall dann halt wenn du eine op brauchst 80000 euro oder 80000 dollar
bezahlen müssen die nicht hasst ja kann jeder malen wie er will freedom hat seine vornachteil
hast du eigentlich schon was für die weihnachtszeit gefunden geschenktechnisch
nö ich habe auch noch gar nicht geguckt heute ich muss steuer erklärung fertig machen noch
heute wird zeit cringe richtig cringe steuer erklärung machen was genau ist cringe an
steuer erklärung ne nicht über das ältester ding also ja aber mache ich nicht selbst ich muss
ja gar nichts für also es war jetzt übertrieben ich mache gar keine steuer erklärung fertig ich
druck ich drucke noch nicht maus ich packe alle rechnungen die ich geschrieben habe bzw ich
bekommen habe in google drive ordner und mache eine tabelle ein und ausgaben und dann schaere
ich das beim steuerberater und der macht es fertig bezahlen berater mann doch ich bezahle
da schon mehr der macht für mich die steuer erklärung und der macht für die firma die
steuer erklärung und ich bezahle da bestimmt 400 400 400 bis 500 euro für insgesamt aber
das auch mit abschreibung und alle möglichen geschiss dabei aber ist mir trotzdem wert
weil ich keinen bock hab den kram selbst zu machen was bekommst du etwa zurück ich weiß
es gar nicht mehr was es war ich glaube ich glaube tatsächlich letztes letztes jahr habe
ich zu viel youtube sehr laut gemacht ich glaube gar nix ich denke mal gar nichts ich
habe wahrscheinlich zu viel eingenommen letztes jahr
kannst du dich einsuchen der auf prozent basis arbeiten ist wahrscheinlich noch teurer oder
mann machst du die steuer erklärung wegen youtube twitch stuff ja auch auch wegen youtube
twitch stuff also ich mache ja zwei muss ja zwei dinger machen einmal für youtube twitch
stuff und einmal für mich privat
every apartment needs this nein das ist ein esp das ist ein d1 mini an seiner klingel
easy as fuck sowas habe ich auch gebaut aber besser ich habe es im raspberry pi gebaut
und im analog digital konverter und dann gucke ich wenn es über 24 volt ist dann weiß ich
dass es geklingelt hat dann rufe ich das handy an über sip und plände über den sip call
am handy die kamera ein dass ich gucken kann am handy wer vor der tür steht way to dank
für
Leute, es ist zwölf, ich hab Hunger.
Ihr kennt mich, ihr kennt mich, es gibt zwei Sachen bei mir, 22 Uhr Bettge und Sonntag
zwölf Uhr, Bettge, Bettge, Klo und Futter, naja, es gibt Sachen, da kommt man nicht drum
herum, niemand, niemand auf dieser Welt kommt an Schlafen, Klo und Essen vorbei, zumindest
nicht lange, nicht lange.
Was gibt's?
Nudeln von gestern, Spaghetti, Weilschuh, Bettge, Klo, Futtern, der Sleep, ja, es gibt
Sleep 3600, 2600 ist eine Stunde, 3600 Sekunden, wie sieht das jetzt eigentlich im Manifest
3 aus?
Lange nichts mehr von gehört, es wurde ja erst mal abgeblasen, hab ich mitbekommen,
ich hab mir ein bisschen mehr geplant für nächstes Jahr, mal gucken, aber soll mir
recht sein, dann wird wieder ein bisschen mehr Firefox verwendet, deswegen ist es auch unglaublich
wichtig, dass wir noch einen alternativen Browser haben, weil sonst könnte Google wirklich
alles machen, ansonsten kannst du halt sagen, ich verwende Firefox, würde ich auch machen,
also wenn da irgendwas kommt in Chrome, mit dem ich überhaupt nicht leben kann, verwende
ich halt Firefox, Opera gibt's ja nicht mehr in der Form, Opera ist jetzt ja quasi ein
Chrome clone, Chrome based, aktivieren können sie es ja, solange die das alte noch weiter
unterstützen, das ist ja das, Chrome wollte das alte ja ausschalten, ja, werden sie, wenn
beide was haben, mit dem du hier witz an Netscape, ey, IE, wenn schon, dann gehe ich zurück
auf Windows 8, 9 und IE 4, nice, ok, ich würde sagen, Fettgetime, ich geh jetzt mal was essen,
vielleicht nachher noch ein paar Runden Battlefield, noch die wochenenden Noobs bisschen bashen,
wir sehen uns bis dann, macht's gut CU.